TENTH HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE ARE
TODAY WE HAVE TWENTY THREE BILLS
UP. AYE TEN OF WHICH ON CONSENT.
.
AS A REMINDER WE ALLOW TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT INTO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR EACH
BILL EACH OF THESE WITNESSES
SHOULD LIMIT THERE'S TESTIMONY
TO TWO MINUTES. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES MAY ADD THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION BY STATING ONLY
THEIR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
GIVEN THE LENGTH OF TODAY'S
AGENDA WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
HONOR THESE TIME LIMITS. OUT OF
RESPECT FOR EVERYONE WHO IS HERE
TO TESTIFY TODAY WILL GO AHEAD
AND START IS A SUBCOMMITTEE WE
ARE WAITING FOR A COUPLE OTHER
MEMBERS. AND.
SO I HAVE MISSED AGUIAR CURRY.
UP IF YOU CAN
IT'S COME UP
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. AB TWENTY TWO NINETY TO
INVEST IN A BETTER SYSTEM OF
CARE FOR OUR CHILDREN BY
INCREASING THE STATE'S CAPACITY
TO SERVE THEM.
THIS WILL BE THIS BILL WILL DO
THIS IN THREE WAYS.
FIRST AB TWENTY TWO NINETY TWO
WILL INCREASE THE RATE PAID TO
CHILDCARE CENTER BASED PROGRAMS.
CARE FOR INFANTS BY INCREASING
THE INFANT TODDLER RATE FACTOR.
SECOND IT WILL CREATE AN
INCLUSIVE GRANT PROGRAM
UTILIZING ONE TIME FUNDS.
TO REMODEL OR RENOVATE AND
EXPAND FACILITIES THE SERVE
CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO FIVE IN
HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES.
AND THIRD IT WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDS TO
RECRUIT AND TRAIN A NEW
GENERATION OF FAMILY CARE.
A CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
AS A SINGLE MOTHER I KNOW FIRST.
HAND HOW HARD IT IS TO FIND GOOD
QUALITY CHILDCARE THAT IS
CONVENIENT AND AFFORDABLE.
IT IS DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND CARE FOR
INFANTS FROM ZERO TO THREE.
THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
PARENTS FACE THIS DILEMMA.
THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO COBBLE
TOGETHER WHATEVER CHILD. CHILD
CARE THEY CAN FIND ARE GOING
WITHOUT IT ENTIRELY.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
WE NEED TO SUPPORT PARENTS SO
THEY CAN GO TO WORK KNOWING THAT
THEIR CHILDREN ARE BEING
SUPPORTED AND NURTURED. DURING
THE IS MOST CRITICAL
DEVELOPMENTAL YEARS OF THEIR
LIVES.
BY EXPANDING THE STATE'S
CAPACITY TO SERVE OUR CHILDREN
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY TWO WILL
ENSURE THAT A CHILD'S PATH TO
SUCCESS STARTS THE SECOND HE OR
SHE IS BORN.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OUR DONNA SNEERING JR OF
THE CHILDCARE RESOURCE CENTER
AND NINA BOTH THE.
BUT NO SAID THERE APPROVED THE
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
DEVELOPMENT. A CHILD DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION.
YOU COULD OFFER NO NEED TO PAY
FOR YOU SEE CDA.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY TWO WILL
INVESTING CALIFORNIA'S TALKER
SYSTEM IN EFFORT TO SERVE A MORE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS IN
CALIFORNIA WEBER CURRENTLY
SERVING ONLY ONE IN EVERY SEVEN
SEVEN ELIGIBLE CHILDREN.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE FIRST
THREE YEARS OF LIFE FOR CRITICAL
TO LONG TERM BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
AND THE QUALITY OF A CHILD'S
ENVIRONMENT HAS A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON THAT BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT.
AN INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE BY THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE FOR RESEARCH
ESTIMATED THAT THAT TITLE FIVE
GENERAL TALK HER PROGRAM WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERFUNDED. AS A
RESULT MANY CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS HAVE CLOSED INCLUDING
AT LEAST SEVENTEEN INFANT
TODDLER PROGRAMS IN LA LAB
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND OTHER HIGHER EDUCATION
SETTINGS.
OVERALL SERVICES FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS IN TITLE FIVE GENERAL
CHILD CARE HAVE DROPPED FROM
ABOUT SEVENTEEN THOUSAND AND TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT TO ONLY
ELEVEN THOUSAND TODAY A DROP OF
OVER THIRTY SIX PERCENT.
AB TWO TWO NINE TWO ADDRESSES
FOR CRITICAL NEEDS I'M FOR
INFANT TODDLER CARE. IT
INTERRUPTS THE LOSS OF INFANT
TODDLER CLASSROOMS I'M SERVING
LOW INCOME CHILDREN BY
INCREASING THE RATE PAID FOR
CARE. DIRECT CONTRACTORS
RECEIVING FUNDING FROM THE STATE
I'M RECEIVE A STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE WHICH IS
LARGELY INTACT ADEQUATE TO FULLY
FUND HIGH QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY TWO YEAR WILL
INCREASE THE ADJUSTMENT FACTORS
FOR INFANT TODDLER PROGRAMS TO
COVER THE COST OF RUNNING HIGH
QUALITY TITLE FIVE CENTER
PROGRAMS. WHICH INCLUDE A ONE TO
THREE INFANT ADULT TO CHILD
RATIO AND A ONE TO FOUR TODDLER
CHILD RATIO. INCLUDING CHILD
ASSESSMENT ENVIRONMENTAL RATINGS
AND MORE.
AB TWO TWO NINE TWO ALSO
ESTABLISHES A GRANT PROGRAM TO
CREATE AND RENOVATE CLASSROOMS
FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS TO
REDUCE LONG WAITING LISTS
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION AT
LARGE NUMBER OF CLAY INFANT
TODDLER CLASSROOMS WERE
CONVERTED TO PRESCHOOL
CLASSROOMS. THIS GRANT WILL
ALLOW PROGRAMS TO PURCHASE
MATERIALS AND RENOVATE
CLASSROOMS TO BE APPROPRIATE FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS TO SERVE
MORE OF THOSE POPULATION IT ALSO
ADDRESSES SOME ADDITIONAL QUITE
EXTORT SHORTAGES IN CHILDCARE
FACILITIES. AND REVERSES THE
LOSS OF LICENSED FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOMES WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWO TWO NINE TWO AND
ARCHER BY BOTH THANK YOU. YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THOMAS NARINDER WITH
THE CHILDCARE RESOURCE CENTER SO
AS NOT TO DUPLICATE WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND HAS ALREADY
SAID ABOUT THE BILL I'M GOING TO
FOCUS ON THE FAMILY CHILDCARE
ASPECT.
I'M IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
CALIFORNIA'S LOST OVER THIRTY
PERCENT OF ITS FAMILY CHILDCARE
CAPACITY. AND FAMILY CHILDCARE
IS CRITICAL BECAUSE IT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF FAMILIES IN A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENCE SITUATIONS
INCLUDING AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
NONTRADITIONAL HOURS OF CARE
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE AND
LINGUISTICALLY SENSITIVE.
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED AND THEY
CAN PROVIDE MAKE STAGE GROUPS SO
THEY CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF A
SINGLE FAMILY IN ONE LOCATION.
ARE THESE ARE FOUNDATIONAL
PROGRAMS IN OUR COMMUNITY THEY
ARE IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS AND
THEY ARE CONVENIENT FOR
FAMILIES.
AND THE LOSS OF THESE PROVIDERS
IS A HUGE CHALLENGE FOR FAMILIES
PARTICULARLY WITH INFANTSAND
TODDLERS MOST INFANTS AND
TODDLERS ARE CARED FOR IN THE
SMALLER SETTINGS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE SOME
INVESTMENT. SO THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE A ONE TIME INFUSION OF
FUNDING INTO AN EXISTING PROGRAM
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE
INITIATIVE PROJECT.
AND IT WOULD BE TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN NEW PROVIDERS THE
CHILDCARE INITIATIVE PROJECT IS
AN EXISTING PROGRAM IN YOUR
STATE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
AGENCIES THEY'RE OPERATING IN
EVERY COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THEY HAVE A SERIES OF TRAININGS
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO HELP PEOPLE
GET THEIR DOORS OPENING GET INTO
BUSINESS.
SO WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS GIVING
AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
TAKE EXISTING CURRICULUM IN
EXISTING TRAINERS AND TRAIN
MORE.
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
I THINK YOU.
AARON GABLE IN BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA SPONSOR HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BELL JUST
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE BUT
I'M ALSO HERE. ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY FIRST FIVE SENIOR
COMMITTEES ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL FOR SITE LOS ANGELES FOR
SPIKES AND PORTANTINO.
FIRST FIVE SANTA CLARA AND
FIRST BITE SANTA CRUZ THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KENDRA
HARRISON WITH CHILD ACTION INK
OR SACRAMENTO COUNTIES RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL AGENCY WERE IN
TRONG SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND
WE ASK YOUR RIFLE.
THANK YOU.
CAN LUIS REPRESENTING CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
DIVERT SCARCE DROUGHT THREE
SIXTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CITIES ALLEN
DOVID THAT MASS PROJECT
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HELLO AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR AT.
NOT FOR EQUITY IN EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I HAD A NORTH CALIFORNIA TELL
DEVELOPMENT MINISTRIES
ASSOCIATION IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MONICA SAMMY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DIONNE AARON ON BEHALF OF THE
SEIU STATE COUNCIL IN UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS APPS ME IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU.
THE SMELL RIGHT MIND ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RON
RAPIDLY HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DANIELLE KENDO BECAUSE OUR ON
BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
A WEST SANDS WITH UNITED WAYS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CINDY ME EMBRACE
WITH MISSION NEIGHBORHOOD
CENTERS HEAD START.
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRIS LEFT WHILE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ALLIANCE OF YMCAS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU DON'T BRING IT UP TO
THE DIET AND QUESTIONS FROM
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
CLEARLY WE NEED TO DO MORE
MANDEL'S OF TESTIMONY WAS GIVEN
IF WE ALREADY KNOW THAT THESE
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT FORMATIVE
YEARS WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE IN YOUR BILL. HELPS.
TAKE US LONG THAT WAY SO THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
KATE IN THE IN THE MEANTIME CAN
WE ESTABLISH QUORUM BEFORE.
WE CONTINUE I THINK YOU.
REVIEW.
DUTCH CHOI.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S.
STONE.
THURMOND.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM QUE
WHICH LIKE THE.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I SIMPLY OUT OF A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE IN REMEMBER
ALSO THAT THIS LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
IS WHEN THEY'RE PRIORITY BILLS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE A MOTION THE
SECOND.
A I A RECOMMENDATION TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DR GOING ON
KNOCKED CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
GRASS.
VARIOUS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
IT'S GOT PORTER'S DERECHA
THANK YOU THAT BOB DOLE MOVES
OUT BRING THINK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA
.
BOB WHAT WAITING.
MYSTERIOUS.
I WOULD LIKE TO DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
JANET RENO.
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR ITEM
NUMBER TWO OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER THREE.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA. DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. A. B.
NOT ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO DO PASSED TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIX OH
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY YOU
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN GET PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB THIRTY
SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VARIOUS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY A. B. THIRTY
EIGHTY TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER DO PASSED TO
THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI I'M GONNA.
MAIENSCHEIN. VARIOUS.
THERE'S AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
FORCE YOU.
THANK YOU THAT PASSES FOR ZERO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA WELCOME
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
BEFORE I GO ANY FURTHER ADDS
MORE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
FOR ALLOWING US THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE NINETEEN
WITH A GREAT APPRECIATION TO
YOUR STAFF FOR AN EXCELLENT
ANNOUNCES THAT CAN PROVIDES. OF
REALLY WONDERFUL REVIEW OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WITH
THIS BILL BUT GIVEN THE DESPITE
THAT HAVE BEEN PREPARED THAT
GRAY AT HOUSES WE GIVE YOU TO
EXPECT NATION ABOUT WHAT TRYING
TO ACHIEVE THIS AFTERNOON. ON AB
TWENTY ONE NINETEEN BUILDS ON
EXISTING FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
REQUIREMENTS TO BREAKDOWN
MISINFORMATION AND STEREOTYPES
ENSURE THAT TRANSGENDER AND
GENDER NON CONFORMING USE YOUTH
HAVE ACCESS TO CARE AND SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED.
NOW TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING USE ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER REPRESENTED IN CALIFORNIA'S
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES ASSESS THE
HEALTH NEEDS OF ALL CHILDREN ARE
IN FOSTER CARE AND ENSURE THAT
THEY RECEIVE APPROPRIATE CARE
AND TIMELY CARE TO ADDRESS. OF
THE NEEDS OF THEIR NEEDS BY
QUALIFIED PROFESSIONALS
NOW UNFORTUNATELY AS YOU MIGHT
IMAGINE SAMPRAS PERSONNEL CARE
GIVERS AND PROVIDERS. OF MAY NOT
ALWAYS. PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
ACCESS BUT HE'S NOT CLOSELY
COMPETENT. THIS KIND OF DENIAL
OF CARE.
IS REALLY DETRIMENTAL TO THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND IS SUBJECT THEM TO UNSTABLE
PLACEMENTS FEW OPPORTUNITIES TO
ACHIEVE PERMITS SEE A LACK OF
ACCESS TO MEDICALLY NECESSARY
CARE THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
THIS IS WHY WE'RE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON. THIS BILL MAKES CLEAR
OF THAT UNDER STATE LAW TO DO IT
THAT I HAD THE OBLIGATION TO
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING USE.
IS WRITTEN INTO THE LAW RIGHT
SO THAT WOULD CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES MUST SECURE ACCESS TO
CLINICIANS OF WHO PROVIDE GENDER
FROM TREATMENT CONSISTENT WITH
ESTABLISHED STANDARDS OF CARE.
IN THIS WELL I JUST TAKE A
MOMENT AND MAKE SURE THAT WERE
EXTREMELY CLEAR THAT WE ARE NOT
CHANGING THAT THE MODES OF
CONSENT FOR THIS KIND OF CARE.
AS IS CURRENTLY THE CASE MANY
FOSTER CHILDREN MUST BE RECEIVED
THE APPROVAL OF THEIR PARENTS
BEFORE THEY GET MEDICALLY
NECESSARY CARE THIS BILL WOULD
NOT CHANGE THAT. IN THE EVENT IN
THE INSTANCES WHERE FOSTER
WEAPON OF PARENTS ARE NOT
CAPABLE OF PROVIDING THAT
DECISION AS MANY CAN'T TODAY
THERE ARE OTHER PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE FOR OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
SOCIAL WORKERS COURTS. A FOSTER
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES THAT CAN
PROVIDE THOSE DECISIONS THIS
WOULD SIMPLY LINE THIS KIND OF
CARE WITH ALL THOSE OTHER KINDS
OF CARE BEGIN PARENTS CAN
PROVIDE CONSENT FOR OTHER OF.
ADULTS I CAN PROVIDE CONSENT FOR
IT THAT'S NEEDS TO BE MADE
REALLY CLEAR ON THE RECORD MADAM
CHAIR.
AND NOW THIS NEED TO PROVIDE A
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE IS URGENT
AND YOU MAY NOT KNOW THAT SO I'M
TRYING TO EDUCATE YOU I'VE HAD
TO LEARN A LOT MYSELF. A THAT
FOR ADOLESCENTS IN PARTICULAR
WITHHOLDING CARE TO THIS KIND OF
TREATMENT UP PROLONGS AND REALLY
EXACERBATES GENDER DYSPHORIA
CONTRIBUTING TO OF VARIOUS
FEATURES THAT ARE NOT IDEAL I
PROVOKE A ABUSE IN
STIGMATIZATION OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT WE WANT TO GIVE YOUNG
PEOPLE THE BEST START IN LIFE
POSSIBLE WE BELIEVE BY DOING
THIS IT GIVES THEM A CHANCE TO
HAVE EXACTLY THAT. GENDER
AFFIRMING TREATMENT INVOLVES AN
INDIVIDUALIZED APPROACH TO
PERMITS A TRANSGENDER AND GENDER
NON CONFORMING YOUTH AND YOUNG
ADULTS TO EXPLORE AND UNDERSTAND
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY AT THEIR
OWN PACE. GIVING THEM THE ROOM
TO FOCUS ON OTHER IMPORTANT
ASPECTS OF LIFE THAT EVERY CHILD
WANTS TO OR SHOULD BE DOING
WHICH IS SUCCEEDING IN SCHOOL.
BUILDING HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
INNING PULLING GAUGING THE
POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETEEN WILL
ESTABLISH A TRANSGENDER AND
GENDER NON CONFORMING YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE CHILDREN THAT ALL OF
US COLLECTIVELY HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR. OUR HAVE
ACCESS TO MEDICALLY NECESSARY
CARE AND TREATMENT FOR GENDER
DYSPHORIA SAID THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE CAN THRIVE.
THIS AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH ME A
DOCTOR JENNIFER HASTINGS WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF MEDICAL
PROGRAMMING FOR THE GENDER
SPECTRUM ORGANIZATION. WELL ON
THE CHEESE DOCTOR GUY HASTINGS
IS ON THE MEDICAL ADVISORY BOARD
FOR UCSF CENTER OF EXCELLENCE
FOR TRANSGENDER HELP. AND DOCTOR
HASTINGS IS AN ASSISTANT
CLINICAL PROFESSOR AND AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR FOR USE YES
THAT'S THE PARTNER AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY MEDICINE NOW IS JUST A
FRACTION OF WHAT OF WHAT DOCTOR
HASTENS BEEN UP TO. ALSO WITH US
THIS AFTERNOON IS NAY THINK
LAUGHS GLASS BUT NATHAN IS
SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD AND LIVES IN
A GROUP HOME IN CULVER CITY. ON
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE WILL TURN
OVER THE WITNESSES.
BUT CONDUCTOR HASTINGS.
THANK YOU WHILE YOU.
SET MY TIMER SO YOU'VE READ MY.
THE THINGS I'M DOING SO I'VE
BEEN PROVIDING GENDER CARE.
INTENSIVELY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THREE.
SUPPORTING APPROPRIATE ACCESS TO
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE FOR YOUTH
IN OUR FOSTER SYSTEM WILL
GREATLY IMPROVE THE STABILITY
AND LONG TERM HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN.
I HAVE SUPPORTED FOSTER YOUTH
WHO WERE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS CARE
IN THEIR OWN COUNTIES.
THIS WAS NEVER ACCEPTABLE AND AB
TWO TWENTY ONE NINETEEN S. R.
OPPORTUNITY TO RIGHT A WRONG.
WITHHOLDING APPROPRIATE CARE HAS
WORSENED MENTAL HEALTH
INCREASING INCREASING DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND SUICIDAL IDEATION.
IN FACT THE NUMBERS SHOW THAT
THING THAT ARE TRANSGENDER YOUTH
I HAVE THE HIGHEST RATE OF
SUICIDAL IDEATION AND SUCCESSFUL
SUICIDE.
WE HAVE EVIDENCE THAT DELAYING
ARE NOT PROVIDING CARE IS NOT A
NEUTRAL ACT WHICH YOU REFERRED
TO.
SUICIDE AND SELF HARM INCREASE
WHEN TRANSGENDER PEOPLE ARE
UNABLE TO ACCESS CARE.
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE AMERICAN PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS AND OTHER
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS.
RECOGNIZE THAT ACCESS TO GENDER
FUHRMAN TREATMENT BOTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND MEDICAL
CARE IS CRITICAL TO THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF TRANSGENDER
AND GENDER EXPENSES PEOPLE.
WE ARE GUIDED BY STANDARDS OF
CARE FROM THE WORLD PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF TRANSGENDER
HEALTH AND THE ENDOCRINE SOCIETY
WHICH HAS A CLINICAL PRACTICE
GUIDELINE THAT WAS JUST
PUBLISHED TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
WHICH EMPHASIZE AS YOU DID AN
INDIVIDUALIZED APPROACH TO CARE.
ALL YOUTH NEED AND DESERVE
EDUCATED KNOWLEDGABLE FROTH
PROFESSIONALS.
WHO CAN SUPPORT BOTH FAMILIES
AND YOUTH?
THE CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA
DESERVE.
EVIDENCE BASED TIMELY CARE BASED
ON GENDER FOR MEN PRINCIPLES.
AB TWENTY ONE NINETEEN PROVIDES
NEEDED SUPPORT FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT THEN.
A HIGH AND NATHAN THEY WERE
INTRODUCED ME BUT.
.
I'VE BEEN IN FOSTER CARE OF IN
AND OUT WITH MY. MY FAMILY FOR
ABOUT THREE YEARS.
TWO I'VE BEEN IN THIS PLACEMENT
WHICH HAS HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BRICK WALLS.
STARTING TRINKET TRANSITION IS
MALE.
EVERY TIME I'D BRING UP.
WANTING TO START TREATMENT THEY
WOULD DRIVE THEIR FEET.
AND
NEGLECT
MY HEALTH RIGHTS.
.
IT TOOK ABOUT A YEAR TO FINALLY
BRING IT UP TO MIKE JUDGE WHICH
WAS ALSO ANOTHER BRICK WALL SHE
WASN'T REALLY. IN SUPPORT OF IT
THE FIRST COUPLE TIMES UNTIL I
PROVED THAT ICAN MAKE MY OWN
DECISIONS AND.
AND ALL THAT OF THEM.
NOT BEING ABLE TO ACCESS.
THE HEALTH CARE THAT I NEEDED
BECAUSE A LOT OF.
DEPRESSION AND STRESS AND I
FELT VERY LIKE.
UNWANTED AND JUST.
.
JUST ALL OF THAT OF. BUT. SINCE
GETTING IT OF MY MENTAL HEALTH
AND EVERYTHING IT'S IMPROVED A
LOT HAPPIER AND I FEEL MORE
IMPORTANT AND.
HAPPY THAT I'VE GOTTEN ACCESS TO
SOMETHING THAT.
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FROM
SQUARE ONE.
.
YEAH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
TAKE I AT HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'M.
YES THIS IS A ALLOCATION FROM
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR LESBIAN
RIGHTS AND WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS BEING
CONSISTENT WITH THE BEST
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES AND
STANDARDS OF CARE FOR
TRANSGENDER YOUTH. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WHERE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AND OBVIOUSLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE
THE SAD THE SUPPORT AND CO
SPONSORSHIP. OF LAMBDA LEGAL AYE
THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY AND THE SUPPORT OF
TRANSGENDER LAW CENTER THANK YOU
THINK YOU.
I. YOU CAN.
BY GOD KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE ALSO VERY PLEASED TO A CO
SPONSOR OF A SPELL. AND ARE
OBVIOUSLY HEARINGS APART AND
ALSOSPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
LA LGBT CENTRE WHICH OF. OUR
SPONSORS AND NOT ABLE TO BE HERE
THANK YOU.
MELISSA ADAMSON ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATHY'S UNKNOWING OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DANTE GOLD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GPT HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEXANDRA CHASE LONG PART OF
TRANS LIFELINE IN FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MANY OF ONE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN CAN WE PEDIATRIC
CALIFORNIA DIVISION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
IN SUPPORT THANK.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SYSTEM POWER LANCER CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS SPORT THANK YOU.
ADDRESS AND ADELE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GET.
STEPHANIE I'VE THEIR CALIFORNIA
LINES OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
DO I HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CAN YOU MAKE SOMETHING PUT IN
PLACE THANK YOU BOTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
MY NAME'S DOCTOR ANDRE THEM ALL.
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY PHYSICIAN
AND A NINE TIME FOSTER PARENT I
ALSO REPRESENT THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF PEDIATRICIANS I ASK
YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FOSTER CHILDREN BE FORCED INTO
WHAT I CALL A DANGEROUS PROTOCOL
THAT ACTUALLY LACKS PROVEN LONG
TERM SAFETY AND EFFICACY FOR A
CONDITION THAT OVERWHELMINGLY
GOES AWAY ON ITS OWN.
THE DISTANCE RATE FOR GENDER
DYSPHORIA IS EIGHTY TO NINETY
FIVE PERCENT BY ADULTHOOD
ACCORDING TO PROFESSIONAL
LITERATURE.
UNDERLYING ISSUES ARE WHAT FIRST
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED THAT'S
WHERE THE STATE SHOULD BE
PUTTING ITS MONEY.
THOSE UNDERLYING ISSUES CAN BE
MANY AND FOSTER CHILDREN ARE
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE THEM.
EXACTLY BECAUSE THE KIND OF
FAMILY DISRUPTION THE PUT THEM
INTO THE SYSTEM IN THE FIRST
PLACE THERE'S LOTS OF THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE DEALT WITH
BEFORE RUSH. THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION'S TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
HANDBOOK ON SEXUALITY IN
PSYCHOLOGY.
PACIFIC WE CAUTIONS AGAINST WHAT
THEY CALL A RUSH TO AFFIRM IN
TRANSITION THAT RUNS THE RISK OF
NEGLECTING INDIVIDUAL PROBLEMS
THE CHILD MIGHT BE EXPERIENCING.
THE RISKS AND PERMANENT
CONSEQUENCES THE MINOR
UNDERGOING TRANSITIONING ARE
SOBERING AND IT MAKES ONE A
PATIENT FOR THE REST OF ONE'S
LIFE AND CHILDREN DON'T GRASP
THAT YET.
THE LONG TERM BENEFITS AND
SAFETY FOR CHILD UNDERGOING
HORMONAL THERAPY AND SURGICAL
TRANSITIONING IF THEY CHOOSE TO
PROCEED THAT FAR. HAS NOT BEEN
DOCUMENTED IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
RECOMMEND THIS TO MINORS AS
EVIDENCE BASED ARE SAFE.
THE MEDICATIONS INVOLVED ARE NOT
EVEN FDA APPROVED FOR THIS USE.
YOU'VE HEARD MENTION OF W. PATH
THE WORLD PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR TRANSGENDER
HEALTH THE SPECIFIED THAT TO
DATE NO CONTROLLED CLINICAL
TRIALS OF ANY FEMINIZING
EMASCULATED THING HORMONE
REGIMENTS. HAVE BEEN CONDUCTED
TO EVALUATE THEIR SAFETY SAFETY
AND EFFICACY UC SAN FRANCISCO
CENTER FOR EXCELLENCE OF
TRANSGENDER HEALTH.
SAYS THE IMPACT OF PUBERTY
BLOCKERS ADMINISTERED TO
TRANSGENDER YOUTH IN EARLY TO
BEGIN UNDER TWELVE ALSO HAS NOT
BEEN PUBLISHED.
AGAIN THESE ARE FDA APPROVED FOR
THAT AND THERE'S A TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN RATHER FAMOUS SWEDISH
STUDY LOOKING AT THIRTY YEARS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE FULLY
TRANSITIONED AND THEY HAVE FOUND
THAT THE COMPLETED SUICIDE RATE
IS NINETEEN TIMES THAT. OF THE
GENERAL POPULATION TO KIMBERLY
SOMETHING IS BEING MISSED.
I'M.
REGRET IS NOT RARE BUT WHAT'S
GONE IS GONE.
THERE'S TWO VERY LEFT LEANING
PRO GAY GROUPS YOUTH TRANS
CRITICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
FOURTH WAVE NOW THAT COMPLETELY
OPPOSE TRANSITIONING THERAPY FOR
MINORS PRECISELY BECAUSE OF THE
HIGH RATES OF REGRET ANDY
TRANSITIONING. A CHILD HAS THE
DEVELOPING BRAIN.
THE YET LACK THE CAPACITY FOR
FULL ADULT DECISIONS AND THE
CONSEQUENCES.
AGAIN BETTER TO PLEASE WE YOU'RE
DONE THE OTHER PASSED THE TIME
IT HAPPENED TO ME AS AND SHOOTS
THE PINK MY LIFE AND I'M TIME IT
HURTS BECAUSE I. THINK YOU.
KIM I'M MY NAME IS HAVE ONE VAN
MOL I'M AMOUNT FOR CHILDREN AND
TO.
TWO OF THEM ARE FORMER FOSTER
CHILDREN THAT WE'VE ADOPTED. I'M
I'VE BEEN A PEDIATRIC ONLY PRINT
DELIVERY NURSE TO HAVE MANY MANY
FRIENDS WHO ARE FOSTER PARENTS.
AND TO.
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORK WITH THE
FOSTER CHILDREN THAT ARE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE THEY'RE WORKING.
HOME WORKING WITH THEM SO I JUST
WANT TO TALK TO YOU AS A MOM.
SO MANY OF OUR FOSTER CHILDREN
DIDN'T START LIFE AT THE
NECESSARY BONDING AFFIRMATIONS
THAT A MOTHER AND. FROM A MOTHER
AND FATHER SINCE FOR A FIFTEEN.
NON LOOKED DEMAND THE RIGHT TO
JUST TELL THEM HOW BEAUTIFUL
THEY ARE. AND THE WAVES.
THREE UNIQUELY MADE EXPRESSES
ITSELF AND HOW IMPORTANT THEY
ARE TO THE WORLD.
INSTEAD THEY EXPERIENCED
NEGLECT.
AND I'M EMOTIONAL DISCONNECTION
AND EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL AND
SEXUAL ABUSE.
THEY COME TO US WITH BEHAVIORS.
THAT REFLECT UNMET NEEDS IN
TRAUMA THE OF DEFIANCE LYING
STEALING WORDING EATING
DISORDERS CUTTING. PROMISCUITY
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS OF KNOWN WHAT
WRITINGS GENDER DISCOMFITURE
AND.
ARE JUST BEHAVIORS FROM A CHILD
WHO NEEDS TO BE LOPPED WHERE
THEY'RE AT.
INCOMING THEIR HEART JUST TAKES
TIME.
I'M.
TO ME MONTHS LET THEM KNOW
THEY'RE LOVED AND THERE WERE YOU
WORTHY OF LOVE.
I'M DEVELOPING TRUST WITH US IT
JUST TAKES TIME.
MOST OF THE BEHAVIORS I MENTION
WILL BEGIN TO DECREASE AS TRUST
AND CONNECTION AND HEALING
HAPPENS.
GENDER CONFUSION IS A SIMPLE THE
HATE BEHAVIOR TO WORK WITH US
COMPARED TO THE OTHERS ARM.
WE DO OUR BEST TO PROTECT OUR
FOSTER CHILDREN FROM SELF HARM
AND FROM HARMING OTHERS.
WE LOCK UP OUR MEDICATIONS AND
OUR LIVES.
FEELINGS OF GENDER CONFUSION
AREN'T HARMING THEM THEY'RE IT'S
NOT HARMING ANYONE ELSE.
BUT THIS BILL IS REQUIRING US
FOSTER MOMS TO LEAD THESE
CHILDREN TO MEDICATIONS THE
KNIVES BUT PERMANENTLY HARM TO
REPRODUCTIVE SYSTEMS.
PLEASE LET US USE THE TIME THESE
CHILDREN ARE IN FOSTER CARE WITH
US DEAL THEIR WHOLE BEING AND TO
RESTORE TRUST AND RELATIONSHIPS.
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN VIOLATED
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT THESE
CHILDREN ARE NOT.
WOULD WANT TO BE IN A GENDER
OTHER THAN MY THIRTY IN A SAYS.
BUT I. FEEL IT'S NOT OKAY TO
LEAD THEM TO MEDICATIONS AND
SURGERY THAT WILL PERMANENTLY
AND FOREVER ALTER THEIR BODIES
WHILE THEY'RE STILL A CHILD.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR.
ORGANIZATION.
I CAN WILLIAMS FROM BETHEL
CHURCH IN REDDING AND THAT TOOK
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE EVERY
WEEKEND AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FOLLOWERS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BECAUSE
IT'S AN EGREGIOUS. UP AND HARM
TO CHILDREN THAT AREN'T READY TO
MAKE THESE KIND OF DECISIONS AND
IT'S IRREVERSIBLE THANK YOU.
TODD PETERSON FORMALLY MANAGER
OF SEVERAL OUTPATIENT OF
PSYCHIATRY AND COUNSELING
CENTERS I COMPLETELY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THIS IS IF PASSAGE THIS
LEGISLATIVE CHILD ABUSE MY
OPINION.
CARL CALMLY HIS MINISTRY'S FROM
FOLSOM AND.
I JUST ASK YOU TO VOTE AGAINST
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN SNYDER
PACIFIC JUSTICE INSTITUTE CENTER
CENTER FOR PUBLIC POLICY WEARING
A OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
JONATHAN KELLER PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL WE
OBVIOUSLY ARE DEEPLYSYMPATHETIC
CAN APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLYMAN'S.
ATTEMPTS TO REACH OUT TO FOSTER
CHILDREN BUT. WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT THE
PERMANENT EFFECTS OF THIS BILL
ON AND THE FACT THAT IT'S
IRREVERSIBLE. WHO JUST ASK IF
THEY CONSIDER THE IMPACT THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE ESPECIALLY ON
FAITH BASED FAMILIES AND?
THEIR WORK IN THE FOSTER SYSTEM
AS WELL THANK YOU STRONGLY
RECOMMENDED OPPOSITION.
JEANNE FISHER I'VE BEEN A
FOSTER-MOM AND TO DO THIS WOULD
MAKE IT
JUST THAT MUCH HARDER TO TRY TO
BEAT OMAN.
A HUSBAND DAVID FISHER.
FROM CASTRO VALLEY.
A. WE DID THAT FOSTER PARENTING
FOR FIFTEEN MONTHS IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TRIED TO. CORRECT
SEVENTEEN YEARS THAT THIS
YOU KNOW CHILD IS REJECTED.
OUR MOTHER IN AND DRUG HOMES
FOSTER HOMES WE FINALLY WERE
TRYING TO CATCH HER UP.
SO WE FIRM STRONGLY OBJECT TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH WARNING FROM REDDING
CALIFORNIA EQUIPPED TO LOVE I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM OF THAT THE
MEMBERS.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING A FOSTER MOTHER.
I THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST THINGS THAT.
ANYBODY CAN DO IS TO THE FOSTER
MOTHER FOR SOME OUT TO SOMEONE
WHO NEEDS THAT PERSON IN THEIR
LIFE.
I ALSO WANT TO COMMEND NATHAN
WHO TESTIFIED EARLIER. BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO SEE BOTH
SIDES.
I THINK THAT IF SOMEONE IS
ASKING TO.
JUST BEAT REAFFIRMED FOR WHO
THEY ARE I THINK IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT THAT BE PROVIDED
TO THEM.
I.
EARLIER HER CHEST TO TESTIMONY
FROM A YOUNG MAN WHO WAS PART OF
A GROUP CALLED BORN PERFECT.
AND I THINK THAT FOR ME THAT WAS
TELLING IN EVERY WAY. TO
REMEMBER THAT EVERY CHILD IS
BORN PERFECT.
I.
IT THERE WERE COMMENTS REGARDING
IRREVERSIBLE.
HARM.
THAT IS ONE AREA IT CERTAINLY I
WANT TO KNOW. WHO THE AYE AYE?
IF THERE IS ANY HARM IT'S GOING
TO BE.
.
IMPOSED ON A CHILD OF COURSE WE
WOULD NEVER WANT THAT.
AND I CERTAIN THAT.
MISTER GLORIA WHATEVER COMMENT
THERE ARE THERE THE WHATEVER
COMMENTS ARE REGARDING ANY HARM
THAT THAT WOULD BE ADDRESSED.
BUT I THINK THE CONCEPT OF
PROVIDING SERVICES TO OUR YOUTH
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENT. UP THE
QUESTION OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LAURIE I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY UP
BECAUSE THIS IS.
AN ISSUE OF FOR FOSTER KIDS AND
I JUST WANT TO. UP ASK AGAIN
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL AS.
IF YOU CAN.
BE DELIGHTED THANK YOU NOW CHAIR
SO THE BILL IS INTENDED TO SPUR
DIFFICULTY BECAUSE.
MAKE IT EXTREMELY CLEAR UNDER
STATE LAW THAT TREND TRANSGENDER
FOSTER YOUTH AND UNTUK
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING FOSTER YOU. HAVE THE
RIGHT TO GENDER AFFIRMING
HEALTH.
IT IS WE ADDED TO WHAT IS
ALREADY.
ACQUIRED A RELAPSE.
IN TERMS OF OTHER KINDS OF
MEDICAL NECESSARY.
A PROCEDURES OR OR HAVE
TREATMENTS.
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
SO ADDING THAT TO IT.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS MEAN I'VE BEEN
EDUCATED ON EXACTLY HOW FAR THEY
HAVE TO GO TO GET. A CONSENT TO
GET OTHER KINDS OF MEDICAL
PROCEDURES DENTAL VISITS THINGS
OF THAT NATURE.
THIS WOULD JUST ADD THAT TO
THOSE LIST OF THINGS THAT
ALREADY.
ARE SPELLED OUT AS BEING A OF
PERMISSIBLE FOR A FOSTER YOUTH
WHO IN THIS CASE.
IS A SUBSET OF THAT THE FOSTER
THE TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING USE WAS SO THE WAY
THAT I READ THE BILL IT THAT
SAYS THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. WHICH MEANS
THAT THEY GO TO COUNSELORS UP
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG OR IF
YOU CAN HELP ME THEY CAN GO TO A
COUNTER AND SAY THIS IS WHAT.
I'M FEELING AND.
THE COUNSELOR CAN HELP THEM THIS
IDENTIFY IF THE ART.
CURRENTLY AND THEN ACCESS.
.
CURRENT.
MEDICAL CARE AND CURRENT
PSYCHOLOGICAL APPROACHES TO
GENDER CARE SO THE. WHAT WAS
QUOTED FROM BY THE TESTIMONY FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL IS ACTUALLY NOT? NOT
CURRENT.
AND WE HAVE SOME GOOD EVIDENCE
FROM HOLLAND AND WE HAVE STUDIES
FROM FORTY YEARS. THAT WAS TIME
WORKING MORE WITH ADULT
POPULATION AND NO DOUBT SO SO
MIGHT I QUESTION IS THOUGH THE
NON UP BUT I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL. IS ONLY
ADDING THE THE PIECE THAT SAYS
THAT THEY HAVE.
ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL AND MEDICAL
CARE THEY EVER AND MEDICAL CARE
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE'RE PUSHING
DRUGS THAT WOULDN'T DOESN'T MEAN
THAT'S MY CONCERN BECAUSE THE IT
WASN'T SAID THAT WHERE. HARMING
THE KIDS BY PUSHING THESE DRUGS.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PUSHING OF THE DRUGS IS I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE CLEAR ON
THAT THIS IS JUST. GIVING THEM
ACCESS TO THE OTHER THE HEALTH
CARE THAT THE.
ARE IN SOME CASES IF MAY BE
APPROPRIATE TO USE MEDICATION
BUT THAT'S ABSOLUTELY ON AN
INVID INDIVIDUAL AFTER LEYVA
HEALTH HALF HAS.
THERE'S BEEN A THOROUGH.
YOU KNOW EXPLORATION OR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE YOUTH
IS EXPRESSING.
CAN ALLOWS FOR.
AS A MODERATE CARE THAT YOU ARE
IF I'D I UNDERSTAND THE
PERSPECTIVE YOU PROBABLY COME
FROM ON THIS.
OF THIS BILL WOULD NOT ALLOW A
CHILD TO MAKE THAT DECISION ON
THEIR OWN AND IT WOULDN'T BE
DONE.
AGAIN WITHOUT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WITHOUT A DOUBT.
CONSENT.
IT WOULD NOT BE DONE ABSENT.
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
INVOLVEMENT WHICH IS NORMAL. AND
AND I SAY THIS BECAUSE AND I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS THAT WE
HEAR BOTH SIDES AND THOSE OF YOU
THAT. I EMAILED IN THAT.
MADE PHONE CALLS WE HEARD BOTH
SIDES BUT I'M LOOKING AT IT AS A
MOTHER AND JUST TODAY MY
DAUGHTER'S SICK. AND I CAN'T BE
THERE.
FOR HERS HER APPOINTMENT AT
FOUR FIFTEEN AND I WILL BE HERE.
BUT THE.
DOCTOR REQUESTED A CONSENT FORM
FROM ME SO THAT.
MY SITTER CAN.
CONCEIT CAN TAKE HER TO THE
DOCTOR AND SOLD THOSE RULES HAVE
BEEN CHANGED
RIGHT IF THERE'S.
SOMETIMES A YOUTH WANTS TO GET
MEDICAL CARE THE FOSTER OF
FAMILY CAN STILL BACK.
HOUSE ACTS OF. THE ABILITY TO
CONSENT CORRECT.
BUT THIS JUST ADDS TO THE
EXISTING ARE.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WELL I
THINK I THINK I'D NATION'S
CUSTOMER HE WAS TELLING WORD
TALKING ABOUT.
HOW HE WOULD LIKE TO THAT
ACCESS CARE ON BUT HAD TO GO
THROUGH MULTIPLE HOOPS THAT
DELAYED OF HIS ABILITY TO ACCESS
BECKNER? THIS WE JUST BOUGHT IT
VERY CLEARLY THAT HE HAS THE
LEGAL RIGHT TO ACCESS THAT.
BUT THAT'S NOT INDEPENDENT.
THAT IS OF COURSE WITH.
APPROPRIATE ADULT CONSENT AND A
WITH MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
FOLLOWING A ESTABLISH GOT A
PRACTICES AND IN IN A CONTINUUM
OF CARE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
NO WHICH I LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WOULD JUST CLOSE A MANAGER
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I KNOW YOU'RE
OFFICES HAD AND HAD ALL BUT A
LOT OF WORK INTO THIS. I WOULD
JUST SAY I HEARD THAT THE
TESTIMONY OPPOSITION AND IF
THERE'S ANYTHING YOU NEED OF OUR
OFFICE WE WILL WORK WITH YOU TO
MAKE SURE THIS BILL IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN STAND BEHIND.
BUT WITH A GUARDED THE
PERMANENT AND IRREVERSIBLE
NATURE OF THE CONCERNS OF THOSE
OPPONENTS I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
BY LEAVING THESE CHILDREN IN A
STATE OF GENDER DYSPHORIA
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE MEDICAL
TREATMENT.
DOT IS PERMANENT DOT IS
IRREVERSIBLE AND THAT IS WHAT IS
WHAT IS RESULTING IN THE POOR
OUTCOMES WE SEE FOR OUR
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING FOSTER CARE YOUTH.
WITH YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY WE CAN
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF STOP
STOPPING THAT AND ALLOWING MORE
THESE CHILDREN TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THEIR LIVES GOING FORWARD.
YOU THINK YOU KNOW I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND I DO
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO DO
PASSED TO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. CAN
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
DRESS.
THERE'S AYE STONE STONE AYE
THURMOND.
VILLAGE THREE VOTING EACH ONE
MORE QUE WILL LEAVE THE UP THE
BILLS ON CON WILL BE THAT OPEN
FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THINK EPIC ADVENTURE.
THANK YOU I HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CREEL
.
HE.
I WILL GO AHEAD AND DO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SOMETHING GOES.
FIRST.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR A JUDGING
BY THE QUICKER FIRST AND SECOND
AYE AYE I SUSPECT YOU WANT
BREVITY.
I LIKE EXCEPT THE.
THE THE TECHNICAL NON
SUBSTANTIVE A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND AS YOU KNOW A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO APPROPRIATE I
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO IDEA.
SITE CD ACCESS TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS I RECENTLY AFFECTED
BY THE HORRIBLE DECISIONS. OF
THE A TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN IT REMOVED AYE IT'S EPS UP
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU THINK MEDICARE AND
MEMBERS.
WE ARE HERE TO CO PRESENT AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO A MEASURE
THAT WILL PROVIDE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO ANNUALLY
VULNERABLE.
SEGMENT OF OUR POPULATION AS WE
KNOW.
TPS RECIPIENTS ARE HOMEOWNERS
THEY PAY TAXES MANY OF WHOM HAVE
AMERICAN BOARD CHILDREN IT'LL BE
A SIGNIFICANT AND CRITICAL
IMPACT TO OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
STATE. AND WE NEED TO AS A STATE
CONTINUE TO BE THE RESISTANCE
AGAINST THE ADMINISTRATION. THAT
CONTINUES TO ATTACK OUR
COMMUNITY VOIGTS BOTH IMMIGRANT
AND UNDOCUMENTED AND.
.
VERY VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
I'M GOOD AT THE NEW MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THINK RIVER
REPRESENTED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE LEADERSHIP
OF SOME WOMEN SANTIAGO AND REAL
FOR. A PRESENT IN THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION OUT OF THE COUNTIES
MORE THAN TEN MILLION RESIDENTS
OVER ONE THIRD ARE IMMIGRANT
INDIVIDUALS. AND AN ESTIMATED
ONE MILLION ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
IMMIGRANT PERSONS
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
FAMILIES LARGE CONTRIBUTE TO THE
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
WELL BEING IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER OF FOR
IMMIGRATION STUDIES EIGHTY ONE
TO EIGHTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THE
LABOR FORCE PARTICIPATION RATE
OF THE TPS POPULATION. FOR OUR
FROM HONDURAS HAITI EL SALVADOR
WHICH IT IS WELL ABOVE THE RATE
FOR THE TOTAL US POPULATION OF
SIXTY THREE PERCENT.
ADDITIONALLY THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND US CHILDREN.
IN TOTAL THERE ARE THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE.
PP IT'S BEEN A FISHERIES
NATIONWIDE INCLUDING FROM THE
COUNTRIES OF NEPAL SOMALIA SUDAN
AND SOUTH SUDAN SYRIA AND YEMEN.
MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILIES HAVE LIVED IN THE
U. S. FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS.
THIS IS NOW THEIR COUNTRY AND
THEY CALLED U. S. THEIR HOME.
THEREFORE WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SPORT
THANK YOU.
AARON TAYLOR A MAP OF THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THINK YOU.
KATE.
I ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUE HEARING NONE A OUT BRING IT
UP TO THE GUYS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WHICH LIKE CLOTHES.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK UBER AND I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
CAN WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
REVEALED.
RUBIO AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
BUT NUMBER LEFT.
MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S.
THIS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND
REGIS YOU DON'T CALL THANK YOU.
THOUGH BILLS ON CALL AND IT IS
RECOMMENDED.
I'VE RECOMMENDED IT TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS WILL REVOKE.
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON THANK YOU MEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO YES.
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN TO STAY FOR THE
SPELL FOR YOUR.
THEY'RE ALREADY HERE.
MUCH APPRECIATED.
ALRIGHT.
BUSY DAY TODAY.
WELL AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM HERE TO
PRESENT A AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO. A BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO PROVIDE
JUSTLY DESERVE COMPENSATION.
FOR PROVIDERS OF IN HOME IN HOME
SUPPORT ERVICES OR I JUST
THAT'S
WHO ALSO TRAINED THEIR PEERS.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THOSE
I JUST AS WORKERS TO TAKE THEIR
TIME TO TRAIN EXPAND AND
ENHANCE.
THIS WORKFORCE THAT WILL BE
JUSTLY COMPENSATED FOR THEIR
TIMES FOR THEIR TIME AND THEIR
EFFORTS.
CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA I TO
THIS PROGRAM SERVES OVER FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
RECIPIENTS WITH THE HELP OF OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND
PROVIDERS.
CALIFORNIA CAN EXPECT AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
PROVIDERS TO BE ENROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM BY THE END OF THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FISCAL YEAR.
THIS MEANS THAT PROVIDERS WILL
NEED TO BE WELL TRAINED IN ORDER
TO ASSIST THOSE THAT THEY CARE
FOR AND PROVIDE. THEIR SERVICES
WITH DIGNITY THE I JUST AS
PROGRAM EXPERIENCE A TURNOVER OF
TWENTY THREE POINT SIX PERCENT.
EACH YEAR APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
TWO THOUSAND PROVIDERS NO LONGER
OFFER THESE MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES.
THIS MEANS THAT MEANS THAT
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHO
DEPEND ON THIS CARE WILL NOT
RECEIVE IT BECAUSE THERE WILL BE
A. SHORTAGE OF CAREGIVERS TO
LOOK AFTER THEM.
PROVIDERS THAT.
PROVIDER THE TEND TO THESE
VULNERABLE. POPULATIONS AND
THEIR HOMES AND HAVE LITTLE TO
NO WAY TO LEARN OR OBTAIN ONE ON
ONE GUIDANCE.
THAT WOULD HELP THEM KEEP UP
WITH THE TRAINING SANDERS AND
PROVIDE BETTER ATTENTION TO
THEIR CHARGES AND THOSE THAT
THEY CARE FOR. AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO WILL PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED ASSISTANCE IN ADDRESSING
THE CARING CRISIS IN OUR STATE
ESPECIALLY IN THE LIGHTER. IN
LIGHT OF OUR DOUBLE AGING
POPULATION.
AS WELL AS THE OVERALL WRITTEN
RETENTION CHALLENGES EXPERIENCE
BY THIS VITAL WORK FORCE THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY AYE TO SAYS
WORKERS WHO DO THE JOB ON A DAY
TO DAY BASIS. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S I JUST AS WORKERS
RECEIVE THE RECOGNITION. AND
COMPENSATION THAT THEY DESERVE
ON A PERSONAL NOTE MY MOTHER
ISN'T AYE JUSTICE WORKER MY AUNT
IS TONIGHT SAYS WORKER. AND THE
WORK THAT THEY DO EVERY DAY. TO
HELP THOSE.
BUT OUR MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IS DONE WITH CARE WITH TRUST AND
WITH LOVE. AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED AND THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING PAID FOR THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING.
SO WITH ME HERE TODAY.
THINK US TIFFANY WHITEN OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE HOME
CARE WORKER WHO WILL I WILL
ALLOW TO CHOOSE THEMSELVES THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TIFFANY RIGHT WITH THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION I'M IN SUPPORT OF SPONSORS
OF THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
THE AGES AS PROGRAM EXPERIENCES
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED A
LOT OF TURNOVER AND THEN AS THE
GROWING POPULATION IS SET TO
INCREASE ITS IMPORTANT FOR THE
PROVIDERS TO GET ADEQUATE
TRAINING. IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
BETTER ASSIST OUR CLIENTS AND TO
HELP RETAIN PROVIDERS IN THE
SYSTEM.
THIS TRAINING OF ASIDE FROM
WHAT IS PROVIDED FROM THE PUBLIC
AUTHORITY FOR THE COUNTIES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT OUR
MEMBERS ARE OFTEN AS BY THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE THESE
TRAININGS.
ON ISSUES SUCH AS FLSA OVERTIME
LEAVE AND HAVE NEVER BEEN
COMPENSATED FOR SUCH SO THIS
BILL MERELY I'M ALLOWS THEM TO
GET COMPENSATION THAT THEY RATE
WOULD RIGHTFULLY DESERVED. AND
AS WE ALL KNOW A BETTER TRAINED
WORKFORCE AND ULTIMATELY
PROVIDES FOR BETTER A SERVICE
DELIVERY TO THE CLIENT SO WITH
THAT I WILL I'M PASS IT OVER TO
OUR MEMBER FROM LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHO CAN BETTER EXPLAIN
INC AND.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ANONYMOUS CARL VINSON.
I'M FROM SOLANO COUNTY AND I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AUTHORITY ABOUT THREE A
COMMITTEE AS WELL.
AND A MEMBER OF THE AYE YOU
LOOK AT OUR TWENTY FIFTEEN.
ARM.
A LABOR UNION THAT REPRESENTS
OVER THREE HUNDRED PHONE ABOUT
THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE. A
WORKERS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND OFTEN SOLANO COUNTY AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT.
FORCIBLY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO TO ESTABLISH
PEER TO PEER LEARNING MODEL IN I
JUST THIS PROGRAM.
.
FIVE YEARS AGO.
I BECAME EYES IS AS PROVIDER FOR
NON FAMILY CLIENT.
AND WHEN I FIRST STARTED AS A.
NEW PROVIDER
A FOUND. THE COMMENDATORE AYE
CHVEZ OUR INTENTION TO BE
INFORMATIONAL IMMUTABLE. BUT
QUICKLY LEARNED HOW DIFFICULT.
I'M ONLY CAN BE TO NAVIGATE THE
AISLES OF US. ARM PROGRAM WHEN I
SUFFERED A BACK INJURY ON THE
JOB.
I WENT TO THE ON LOCAL PUBLIC
AUTHORITY OFFICE TO GET. HELP
FOLLOWING FOR WORKERS.
.
UGH A STUDENT A CONVERSATION TO
GET THE HELP I NEEDED TO QUICKLY
GET BACK TO WORK. TO CARE FOR MY
CLIENT.
BUT I WAS GIVEN THE RUN AROUND
FOR ABOUT FOUR MONTHS BUT FOR
THE CARD.
I WAS GIVEN THE RIGHT
DOCUMENTATION TAUNTING THE
MEDICAL HELP.
I NEEDED TO RECEIVE IS GOOD
THERAPY THIS MET MACLEOD WOULD
RECEIVE THAT ARE SERVICES THEY
NEED.
IT WAS WITH THE HELP OF MY
UNION.
A LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN.
R. F. YEAH YOU THAT I WAS ABLE
TO. GET THE SUPPORT I NEEDED TO
SHORE I HAD THE RIGHT
INFORMATION. TO HEAR MY INJURY.
AND TO GET BACK.
A OUGHT TO BE AND.
.
A A A CARE GIVER.
I JUST HAVE PROVIDERS.
I'M LIKE ME IF INSULATED IF
OCELLATED.
I'M SORRY I JUST I JUST AS
PROVIDERS LIKE ME WORKING
OCELLATED ON ENVIRONMENT AND NOT
HAVE TYPICAL COWORKERS.
YOU CAN ASK FOR HELP WHEN YOU
NEED.
.
SUPPORT.
ARE EITHER THROUGH ALL UNION
THAT WE COME TOGETHER AND STAY
INFORMED ABOUT CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM.
AND ORIENTATIONS DO NOT.
PROVIDE DETAILED INFORMATION OR
ARM OR NOT TRINITY.
TWELVE QUESTION ABOUT POLICY THE
BENEFITS PROVIDERS SHOULD KNOW
ABOUT. A IN MY CASE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WORKERS A
CONVERSATION.
I JUST AS PROVIDERS INTO YOU
MEAN HOW TO ON THE JOB
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE.
TO GIVE ADDITIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND
SUPPORT TO ADDRESS PROVIDERS
WHO.
WHO REQUIRE A SPECIALIZED
ASSISTANCE?
TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM
ON BEHALF OF AYE CHVEZ
PROVIDERS. ON THE STATE A ACT
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE FILM THE
BILL 28-7 TO THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT
.
MY NAME IS NICOLE CARTER I'M
WITH SEIU TWENTY FIFTEEN I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THIS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
REPRESENTING HERE REPRESENTING
YOU W. ASKS ME WE REPRESENT
ROUGHLY HUNCHED.
I JUST AS WORKERS IN WE ARE ALSO
A CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THINK.
MY NEW MACHINE RUSSIA BEKOMMEN I
JUST AS PROVIDER AS WELL AS YOU
W. MEMBER LOCAL.
GOING ON THIRTY
UN I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROL MEDINA
I'M A MEMBER OF AYE EACH ASSESS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR ASSEMBLY
DINO COUNTY. AND I AM ALSO A
MEMBER OF AS HE AYE YOU TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN. AND I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CASEY NONE OF BRING IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY I HAVE A MOTION.
.
TO AS AND TO PASS TO ASSEMBLY
PREPARATIONS WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CAN CALL ROLLED.
TO THE ROLE PLEASE.
RUBIO I REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
ARAMBULA ON ARAMBULA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN HIGHER CLASS.
THIS AYE STONE.
BERMAN.
BILLS THAT FOR THE FIRST YEAR
TAKE THE BILLS OUT FOUR TO ZERO
POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE YES.
I JUST WANTED TO I KNOW THE YOUR
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF WOMEN AND
SAID CAN GAUGE MEANT AND JUST
WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO REAM
GUERILLA. AND MY IDEA WHO ARE IN
THE GALLERY THAT PART OF THE AT
NIGHT PROGRAM AND THEY'VE BEEN
SHADOWING ME AND OTHER WOMEN
TODAY SUCH AS ONE I THINK A LOT
OF THEM ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
PAIR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER KALRA
THINKING WELCOMES KALRA.
YOU MAKE GWEN'S.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB THIRTY TWO HUNDRED RESTORES
THE STATE PORTION OF THE S. P.
S. I GRANT.
SO THE TOTAL GRANT AMOUNT IS
RAISE TWO HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL AND
REINSTATE THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT BEGINNING JANUARY.
OF TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN.
WHO OF THE BILL?
I WOULD.
EDU I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT HELPED
CLARIFY THE INTENT OF THE BILL
WHICH TO NOT REDUCE ANYONE'S SS
I. PAYMENTS IN FUTURE YEARS.
AS I S. SP GRANTS OF THE SOLE
SOURCE OF INCOME FOR ONE POINT
THREE MILLION LOW INCOME SEE LOW
INCOME SENIORS. AND PEOPLE
LIVING WITH DISABILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND HELPS INDIVIDUALS
PAY RENT BUY FOOD PAPER
UTILITIES MEDICINE AND OTHER
BASIC NECESSITIES.
BEFORE AS I SPEAK CUTS WERE
TAKEN IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THE
MAXIMUM GRANT WAS ONE HUNDRED
POINT SIX PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. AND TODAY IT IS A
NINE POINT ONE PERCENT.
BECAUSE THERE HAS NOT BEEN A
RESTORATION OF THE S. S. B.
GRANT WE HAVE ALLOWED OVER ONE
MILLION ELDERLY AND DISABLED
CALIFORNIA'S.
TO FALL BELOW THE POVERTY LEVEL.
AND OF COURSE IN CALIFORNIA BE
NO THAT'S ACTUALLY DIRE POVERTY.
THE CURRENT SSI SSB GRANTS ARE
INADEQUATE PER PERSON TO LIVE ON
ESPECIALLY GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S
HIGH COST LIVING
WITHOUT AN INCREASE IN SSB GRANT
THESE INDIVIDUALS WAS
HOMELESSNESS.
AND BASS HUNGER WHICH LEADS US
OBVIOUSLY TO POOR HEALTH.
THE STATE HAS SAVED AN ESTIMATED
TEN BILLION DOLLARS ON THESE
CUTS THAT BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE.
WE HAVE RESTORED EVERY MAJOR
PROGRAM AND THE BUDGET EXCEPT AS
S. B. GRANTS.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO FULLY
FUND CALIFORNIA'S RAINY DAY CASH
RESERVE FUND TO THIRTEEN POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THE LARGEST
CASH RESERVES STATE HISTORY
FURTHERMORE.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
IS PROJECTING THREE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS
THIS YEAR AND I THINK WE KNOW
IT'S GOTTEN TO BE MUCH LARGER
THAN THAT.
GIVEN THE STATE SURPLUS TIME TO
RESTORE THE SSPA GRANT AMOUNT.
THIS RESTORATION WILL HELP
PROTECT THESE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE RIGHT TO
LIVE WITH DIGNITY. NOT POVERTY.
THIS IS AN INVESTMENT NOT A COST
ITS SOLUTION. AT TO OUR SENIOR
HOUSING CRISIS A TEACHERS
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTS POOR
NUTRITION OF THESE POOR HEALTH
OUTCOMES THAT FURTHER STRAIN THE
STATE'S OTHER SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS.
BY INVESTING IN OUR SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES BY
BRINGING THE SSI SP GRANT
AMOUNT.
TO THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL AND
ULTIMATELY SAVE THE STATE MONEY
AND MOST SIGNIFICANTLY WE HAVE
TO REMEMBER THAT THIS IS NOT.
.
AB AND ASK THAT'S GIVING MORE
MONEY TO THIS GROUP OF THIS
GROUP IS ACTUALLY SACRIFICE TO
HELP US GET TO THE RECESSION TO
HELP US BUILD THE SURPLUS WE
HAVE. ON THE BACKS OF SENIORS
LIVING IN POVERTY AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES LIVING IN
POVERTY AND FOR THAT. FOR THOSE
REASONS I I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BOAT. AYE AYE I HAVE TO
MY LEFT MIKE HERALD BUSES CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY AS WELL. AS
A.
CHERYL THURSTON THE PRESIDENT OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF THE BLIND
AND GENET HEITMAN WHO'S A SYSTEM
CHANGE ADVOCATE.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
BOB MADAM CHAIR OF MICRO WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. DID OUTSTANDING
JOB OUTLINING HISTORY IN THE
IMPACTS THAT BUT THESE DUMB
DECISIONS MANY YEARS AGO TO CUT
THE SFE GRANTS OF HAD. BOMB AND
YOU OF COURSE.
GET TO HEAR FROM ME QUITE
FREQUENTLY APPEAR SO I'M GOING
TO PASS MY TIME TO TO THE TWO
WITNESSES HAVE TRAVELED CAN SO
WE CAN HEAR FROM THEM IN THEIR
PERCENT SOURCE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHERYL THURSTON.
.
MANY OF US.
ON SS I LIKE MYSELF RECEIVED AT
NINE HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS
WHICH IS BELOW TO PROBABLY
LEVEL.
A PORTION OF THAT IS ALLOCATED
FOR HOUSING WHICH THEY HAVE
GIVEN US LIKE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
DOLLARS. AND IS NOWHERE IN A
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE CAN READ
BEFORE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
DOLLARS.
WERE ASKING AT THIS TIME IF YOU
WOULD CONSIDER TO ONE HUNDRED TO
ONE HUNDRED. WHICH WOULD GIVE US
A HUNDRED DOLLAR. INCREASE THAT
WOULD BRING US UP TO THE
PROPERTY LEVEL LINE AND ALSO A
HUNDRED DOLLAR INCREASE FOR COST
OF LIVING.
SO PLEASE CONSIDER VOTING YES ON
A. B. THIRTY TWO HUNDRED.
THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU MY NAME IS JEANETTE
HEITMAN I'M A SYSTEMS CHANGE
ADVOCATE WITH SERVICE CENTER FOR
INDEPENDENT LIFE OUT OF
CLAREMONT. AND I ASK YOU
SPECIFICALLY TO APPROVE THIS
BELL MUCH LIKE CHERYL SAYS. NINE
HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS I ASK
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU COULD LIVE
ON.
EVERY MONTH.
WE ARE WAY BELOW THE POVERTY
LEVEL AND ALL WE ARE ASKING FOR.
IS THE DIGNITY OF POVERTY.
AND ISN'T THAT A SAD STATE OF
AFFAIRS FOR CALIFORNIA.
WE ASK THAT YOU APPROVE THAT
SPELL AND HELP US GAIN SOME
DIGNITY WE WILL BE ASKING FOR
MORE I WON'T ASK THAT TODAY YEAH
THAT. THE.
YOU KNOW.
BUT.
HOUSING AND AND JUST SO YOU KNOW
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK OH
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING WHILE YOU
KNOW.
A SUBSIDIZED HOUSING IN LA
COUNTY IS AN ILLUSION IT DOESN'T
EXCESS.
I PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN ON THE
LIST FOR TEN YEARS WAITING FOR
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING I HAVE PEOPLE
IN LA COUNTY THAT I'M SENDING
* SANDRA DINO COUNTY. BECAUSE
AT LEAST THAT WAITING LIST IT'S
ONLY ONE. ONE TO TWO YEARS TO
FIVE YEARS.
OKAY SO WE'RE ASKING PEOPLE TO
LIVE ON WHO ARE AS LITTLE AS
NINE HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS A
MONTH. NOW WE HAVE A LARGE GROUP
OF PEOPLE FROM THE FOOD BANKS
THAT ARE HERE. THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE FEEDING LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
AND IF YOU HAVE NEVER BEEN TO A
FOOD BANK TO GET FOOD AYE AYE
ENCOURAGE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU TO GO TO YOUR LOCAL FOOD
BANK. AND SEE WHAT YOU GET WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT BEEF AND MILK
AND EGGS
AND CHICKEN.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CAN POWDERED
MILK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
BARE ESSENTIALS.
SO I JUST ASK YOU PLEASE
CONSIDER APPROVAL WE REALLY
NEEDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR CLIPPER HERE IN
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE AND JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THINKERS DRIVER.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU CALIFORNIA AWESOME IN
SUPPORT.
JEFF TOM MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL BLIND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
HI KATHY CENTER LINK WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BROUGH SELSUN. A PERSON WHO
LIVED ON EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH.
NO MINUS THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
AMONGST Y. PAPER RENT.
AS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO LIVE
ON.
PER MONTH THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TO RESTORE ALL
AND A MEMBER OF
SHE HAD DISABILITY.
PEOPLE ON SS I DO NOT QUALIFY
FOR FOOD STAMPS
CHAU THEY DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY FOR RENT AND FOOD. PERRIN
IS SO HIGH.
FOR INSTANCE FOR ME I HAVE TO
PAY FOR.
TRANSPORTATION.
PREFERRED.
DO FROM.
GOAL SHOOTER DOCTOR.
BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE THAN FIVE
DOLLARS.
GO AND COME AND GO.
IF GOOD PROSPECT PATIENT DID NOT
COME UP.
GET A TAXI COST ME TWENTY
DOLLARS
I AM IN A FIXED INCOME. IN
HARTFORD.
TIME FOR ME TO MAKE THIS TRIP.
AND AFFORD MY FOOD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHARLES MINSTER A MAP
RESIDENT SAN FRANCISCO A MEMBER
OF SENIOR DISABILITY ACCIDENT
NATIONAL ACTIVE AND RETIRED
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES.
IT'S TIME TO TELL JERRY BROWN
THAT BANKERS HE'S HE'S BEEN
WORKING FOR FOR THE PAST EIGHT
YEARS HAVE GOTTEN THEIR MONEY.
AND IT'S TIME TO GIVE IT TO
PEOPLE WHO DESERVE IT.
PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MAUREEN SIR HALL AND
A VOLUNTEER WITH THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD BANK AND I
COMPLETELY SUPPORT BRINGING ONE
POINT THREE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
OUT OF POVERTY PLEASE FINALLY
PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
EVERYONE ABA HASN'T WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WERE ACROSS DISABILITY
ORGANIZATION INSTRUCTS PART OF
THIS BILL. ALMOND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
SHANNON PRIMER SPECIAL NEEDS.
A PARALEGAL AND. PART OF
EMPOWER FOR I'M ONLY CALIFORNIA
WE'RE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LISA COMMENT OUT CHALCO OF
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION WE LOOK AT
THIS IS A WORK DETERRENT AND A
COST SAVINGS TO THE STATE TO
KEEP POKES OUT OF THOSE LONG
TERM CARE. SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ON MEDI CAL WHICH IS
A CONSIDERABLY HIGHER ALLOCATION
THAN THIS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. THANK YEAH HOME.
CAT THANKS ALMONDS ELOQUENTLY
FROM SAN FRANCISCO ARE GREAT
RECESSION TOOK A LOT OF THE
MONEY OUT OF EACH OF OUR CHECKS.
AND OF THE ECONOMY HAS COME BACK
IT'S BONE I THINK IT'S ABOUT
TIME WE REPLENISH THE SUPPLY
THANK YOU PLEASE PASS THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS COOPER WHY SAP OPEN
CALIFORNIA PASSPORT AB.
THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THINK.
BEVERLY WEST PUTS FORTH. A HOPE
INGESTED AND CAN YOU PLEASE PASS
THIS BILL THANKFULLY.
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA FAIR ON THE
TINY I'M OF
HERE WITH OUR.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL A.
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF AB E. THREE
TWO OH ZERO ZERO AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOUR HELP
THANK YOU.
THAT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DENISE
NORMAN I'M HERE REFERENCE IN THE
HEALTH CARE FOR THE HOMELESS.
PLUS YOU NICE USE OF OPEN
ALAMEDA COUNTY YOU PLEASE PASS
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DAN BRADLEY I LIVE IN
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING AND I'M PART
OF ST MARY'S CENTER HOPING
JUSTICE PLEASE PASS A. B. THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LEE CAMERON PANEL
WITH SENIOR THIS HAVE IMMEDIATE
ACTION. AND.
OF COURSE FAMILIES OF AB HA
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND I WOULD I
WOULD SAY ONE THING.
THIS IS SO MUCH DIFFERENT FROM
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE WE GO TO SAN
FRANCISCO TO THEIR HOME.
CITY HALL.
FOR THEM OF BIRTH SUPERVISORS.
THEY'RE ALWAYS ON THEIR PHONE.
NOT REALLY LISTENING SO THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHARON SCHUSTER
COMING HOPE HOPING JUSTICE CLASS
ST MARY'S.
AND I WISH HIM PAVE.
SUPPORT IS BR SUPPORT THIS PARA
THANK YOU.
WE GOT LOW MULLIN IT PERSON
JOHNSON.
INSTEAD. RELY FOR YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR HEARING US
THANK YOU.
RUSSELL RAWLINGS DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCACY SERVICES FOR RESOURCES
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER
SERVING SACRAMENTO AND YOLO
COUNTY. IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I.
ALEXANDRA AGES LONG ASSOCIATE
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER AT SAINT
MARY SENIOR CENTER IN HOMELESS
SENIOR SERVICES STRONGLY
ADVOCATING THIS BILL BE PASSED
THANK YOU.
BUT WE GOT THEM WRONG WHENEVER
HE SAID IF SAY I'M A BIT OF IS
THE ACCOUNT FOR ALLIANCE WORTH
THAT AMERICA.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. A BIT YOU
THOUGHT GET TO THE HUNDRED.
IT TOPICS MORTON STAY IN YOUR
PAPER DISABILITY ON.
LOW INCOME BROKE BITS
DAY OR CARD ENTIRE LIFETIME.
SO ALL THE MONEY THAT THEY
REALLY ARE IT TO BE SPENT.
REPRODUCTIVE ELBOW CALIFORNIA ON
IT
STIMULATE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HEATHER HARRISON WITH A
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
A GEORGE TICKNER SIXPENCE INK
REPRESENTING SIX BED FACILITIES
OUR RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY IN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BOLIVIA DNA WOULD SIX BY
THINKING TRANSPORT.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU KNOW ONCE LIKE FROM
SIXPENCE INK IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR AFTERNOON ARE THEY USING
GOVERNMENT MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS ALVIN FOR THEM FROM THE CITY
AND FROM THE ACTING SENIOR
MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA. ACCOUNT OF
CONTRA CUSTOM STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY TWO I THINK TANK.
GOOD AFTERNOONS ARE MY NAME WITH
HIS TOOLS UNRATED OF SUBSTANCE
COLUMN. I'M WITH THE COALITION
ON HOMELESSNESS AND HERE TO
SUPPORT. YOU HAV TO SUPPORT IT
WITH A LITTLE HELP A LOT OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE SINGLE FAMILIES
AND SINGLE. ARM.
A PERSON SO PLEASE SUPPORTIVE
AND PATH
.
AS AUSTIN
CLARK.
PROUD SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT COPELAND I
BELONG TO US SECOND HOMES OR NOT
COMMITTING DOT BUT WAS
DISABILITY RIGHTS GROUPS IN
SACRAMENTO THEY FENDED OFF RUN
PEOPLE RUNNING THE FATE OF THE
HALL. AQ SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTY SANTA CLARENCE TALKSPORT
THINK YANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNY CASTILLO ST
MARY CENTER WEST OPEN SENIOR
SERVICE PROVIDER ON A SERVING
HUNDREDS OF LOW INCOME HOUSE
TONIGHT COUNT SENIORS WE SUPPORT
A. B. THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PLEASE
PASS IT. THANK YOU.
ROMANO I HOPE IT'LL SAY MEMORIES
DURING LAST ONLY A FEW TO PAY OF
THIS B. THIRTY TWO HUNDRED THANK
YOU.
COUNTY REBEKAH FENCING ANTHONY
FOUNDATION AND THE TENDERLOIN
NEIGHBORHOOD OF SAN FRANCISCO.
SENIORS AND PEOPLE DISABILITIES
ARE SUFFERING WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THINK IF YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S ERIC FRAME I AM.
HOMELESS ADVOCATE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I'M SEEING MORE AND
MORE HOMELESS ELDERLY FOLK.
THESE DAYS.
I SUPPORT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PERCENT. SSI BUT I'LL SETTLE FOR
POVERTY LEVEL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROLYN MEDINA.
THAT I AM A MEMBER OF THE I HATE
TO ASSESS ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND
I.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I ADVOCATE HIPPIE PASSED THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS WENDY KITTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ELLA
JONES I'M ADVOCATE WITH THE
CONTRA COSTA FOOD BANK.
I AM A POTION FROM THE OTHER
STATES THAT SUPPORT PEOPLE ON
SSI AND I. RECENTLY JUST LEARNED
THAT CALIFORNIA. WAS IN ONE OF
THE STATES AND I WAS APPALLED
AND DISAPPOINTED AT THAT FACT.
I.
EXPECT YOU GUYS TO PASS THAT
BUILDING AT LEAST BRING THEM UP
TO PROBABLY LEVEL BECAUSE IT'S
INSANE.
ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW WITH THE
FACT THAT THE COST OF LIVING
HERE IS HIGH ESPECIALLY FOR
SENIORS IN PEACE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DISABLED THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY. SO I
SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
FULLY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EDWARD WILLIAMS ANNA
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED.
AND.
.
I'VE BEEN IN PRISON FOR THIRTY
YEARS.
HAVE BEEN OUT FOR YEARS AND I AM
IN POVERTY.
AND ARISTOTLE SEE POVERTY.
PARENT.
CRIME.
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
WILLIAM COLLINS I'M WAIT A PLAN.
AND I NOTICED IS A LOTTA ELDERS.
APPEAR
TO PASS THIS BILL.
AND IT MEANS WE'RE NOT FIGHTING
FOR YOU.
WE'VE ALREADY GOT NO.
YOUR TURN.
CARLY THINK WHAT THE.
GRAMMY NIGHT.
IT ON THE SCREEN.
WELL THAT
GRANTED THE SPACES IN TRAILER
PARK.
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE IMPROVE
PROPERTY VALUES
THE RENT IS GONE UP THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
SO HUNDRED WILL HELP BUT IT'S
IT'S NOT REALLY A.
AFFECTS THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON RUBIO
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
MY NAME IS EITHER PARENT TO ON
AND I'M WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK AND I HERE
STANDING IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED. THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI SHANTI PRASAD ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN OAKLAND
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT THIS IS
OUR NUMBER ONE POLICY ISSUE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN THE MORRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PACE
THE PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CRISTINA BUS HAMILTON WITH UT W.
LAUGHS ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CAN YOU READ ABOUT I JUST
PROVIDER LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY YOU GW STRONG SUPPORT
THINK YOU.
AB DAY WITH YOU DETECT BICU
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNGER THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEFF TARGET VIA AFTER KIT.
A HOME.
DISABILITY RIGHTS.
CURA OWL DOG FIGHT THERE'S A
NUMBER OF OTHERS BUT WE'RE
STRONG SUPPORT THAT SOMETHING
NEEDS TO BE DONE FOR SSI.
RECIPIENTS
POLICE SUPPORT THIS AND START
TALKING TO THE GOVERNOR. THANK
YOU.
THROUGH THE ANDERSON ON BEHALF
OF THE ARCANE UCP CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION MONTH PART. THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AND I HAVE A MOTION BY
DOCTOR AROUND THE LAND YOU A
SECOND FOR THE BILL.
WELL AS THE PROUD JOINT AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL I SECOND THE MOTION
THANK YOU SO THAT WAS A MOTION
BY.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA TAKEN BY A
MYSTERY IS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
KATE HEARING NONE OF BRING UP TO
THE DYESS FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
NOT CAKE WHICH. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
BUT THANK YOU MADAM XIN I DO
WANNA THANK.
.
OF MY JOINT AUTHORS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES ASSEMBLY
THURMAN AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
CALL OTHERS INCLUDING. OF COURSE
ARE A HIGH CHAIR HERE THIS
AFTERNOON.
I THINK WE DID HERE SMALL BROAD
RANGE OF FOLKS BOTH ADVOCATES AS
WELL AS THOSE THAT TO THEM
BENEFIT FROM SS I SS P..
AS TO HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS AND.
I KNOW. OFTENTIMES WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU HAVE BILLS LIKE HAS
COME FORWARD AND SOMETIMES YOU
LOOK AT THE PRICE TAG OF MY I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THE PRICE
HAS BEEN PAID MANY TIMES OVER.
BY THOSE THAT HAVE HAVE NOT BEEN
RECEIVING.
THEIR WITH THEIR FULL SHARE UP
TO POVERTY LEVEL. OF SS I SS P..
AND I THINK THAT IF FARM IT WE
HAVE NO OTHER RESPONSIBILITY AYE
DURING OUR TIME LEGISLATURE.
I THINK THAT WHAT WE'RE LEADING
SUFFERING.
SHOULD BE OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO AT LEAST PROVIDE SOME RELIEF
FOR THOSE THAT ARE SUFFERING. UP
WITH THIS BALANCE OPEN AND BUT
THAT HAVE MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
EXPECT THE ASPIRIN AYE BOAT.
THANK YOU I HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND TO.
AND I HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS CAN YOU CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
ARAMBULA A AYE ARAMBULA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S.
THERE'S AYE STONE.
THURMOND.
READ AT YOUR OWN OF TORN OFF THE
BILL A BILL CALLING FOR A IN
ALLOWED THE MEMBERS TO JOIN
THANK YOU YOU.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
.
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH IS COURAGE'S KIDS ON
CAL WORKS.
TO FINISH HIGH SCHOOL AND START
THEIR POST HIGH SCHOOL CAREER
STRONG.
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM IS A
CORNERSTONE OF CALIFORNIA SOCIAL
SAFETY NET THE PROGRAM PROVIDES
ASSISTANCE TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN AND HELPS
THEM GET.
GET TO A FINANCIALLY STABLE
SITUATION.
WITHIN THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM IS
THE CAL LEARN PROGRAM.
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL SERVICES TO
PREGNANT AND PARENTING MINERS IN
CAL WORKS HOUSEHOLDS.
IN ADDITION TO SERVICES MEANT TO
HELP WITH THE CHALLENGES OF
HAVING A CHILD.
CAL LEARNED PROVIDES A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR INCENTIVE GRANT
TO PARTICIPANTS IF THEY GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
THESE GRANTS ENCOURAGE STUDENTS
TO FINISH THEIR EDUCATION AND
HELP THEM PURSUE THEIR NEXT
STEPS LIKE HIGHER EDUCATION
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION OR
ENTERING THE WORKFORCE.
RECOGNIZE THE BENEFITS OF THIS
INCENTIVE
GRANT PROVIDES PROVIDES FOR
CALLIN PARTICIPANTS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN LOS ANGELES COUNTY BEGAN
PROVIDING THE FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR GRANT FOR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION. TO THE REST OF THE
STUDENTS AND CAL WORKS COUNCILS.
THEY ALSO REQUIRED STUDENTS
RECEIVING THE GRANT TO COMPLETE
A MONEY MANAGEMENT CLASS WITH
VALUABLE INFORMATION ON MANAGING
PERSONAL FINANCES.
THIS EXPANDED GRANT HAS NOW
HELPED OVER THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
CAL WORK STUDENTS GRADUATE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN SEEKS
TO EXPAND ON THE SUCCESS OF THIS
BY MAKING THIS A MODEL.
AND A FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THE
CAO WORKS BENEFITS PROGRAM
STATEWIDE WITH ME HERE TODAY ARE
WITNESSES.
WE HAVE.
JACQUI.
MICELLE BUNT BERT FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THANK YOU AND
KATHY CENTER LYING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU AND
WELCOME. MOVE THE BILL.
I'M A MOTION SECOND THINK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
ALL OF US START AND THEN.
YEAH YEAH GIVEN OVER TED JACQUI
TO GIVE THE LOCAL PERSPECTIVE
ACCOUNT THE SENATE OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
VERY PLEASED TO COSPONSOR THIS
BILL WITH THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES.
AT
OUR AUTHOR OBVIOUSLY SOME THAT
UP VERY WELL I WILL SAY I KNOW
THIS HAS BEEN A TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION IN RECENT YEARS OF
HOW DO WE INCENTIVIZE. OF
SUPPORT AND TRY TO ENCOURAGE ALL
OF OUR RECIPIENTS TO GET
EDUCATION FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND
THEY CONTINUE ON INTO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. WHEN WE.
HAVE BEEN TALKING FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WITH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ABOUT THE REALLY COOL
PROGRAM THAT THEY'VE DONE AIMED
AT THE YOUTH WHO ARE NOT CAL
LEARN ELIGIBLE. IT.
ROSE TO THE LEVEL FOR OUR BOARD
OF WANTING TO SUPPORT IT AND
TAKE IT STATEWIDE THIS YEAR
THROUGH THIS BILL AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ON THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT. THE.
SOME OF THE YOUTH MAY HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THESE TYPE OF
THIS YEAR FOR THE ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED AS
PART OF THE BUDGET. THEN FRANKLY
SEEING THE LEVEL OF INTEREST AND
APPLICATIONS FOR THAT COUNTIES
RAN OUT OF MONEY AND SO WERE
REALLY TARGETING THIS TO THOSE
USED TO THOSE HIGH SCHOOL
RECIPIENTS AND HOPING NOT JUST
FOR THEM TO GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL.
BUT ALSO HELP BREAK THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY BY GIVING THEM A
FOOTHOLD TO BE ABLE TO NOT HAVE
TO ENTER THE WORKFORCE RIGHT
AWAY OR TO SUPPORT THEM IN GOING
TO COLLEGE AT LEAST PART TIME IF
NOT FULL TIME. AS THEIR NEXT
STEP WE THINK.
THAT I EVEN THE FIVE DOLLARS
DOES THAT MAYBE SOUND LIKE A LOT
TO YOUR TO YOUR ME SITTING HERE
ON FOR SOMEONE FROM A LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLD THAT CAN BE A LOT AND
THAT CAN REALLY HELP THEM GET TO
THAT NEXT STEP. ITEM IS MY THE
BIRD HAS SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT
AND I'D LOVE TO I'M JUST GIVE IT
TO HER TO TELL THAT LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU.
THEY KEEP. MAHOOD JERUSALEM'S.
I'M JACKI WAS ALBERT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I WON
ACQUITTAL FACES IN TERMS OF SOME
EXPERIENCES THAT WE HAD. ABU AS
KATHY SAID OUR GOAL INITIATE
THIS PROJECT WAS TO BREAK THE
CYCLE.
OF POVERTY AND DEPENDENCE ON
WELFARE.
I AM.
LOOK AT WE LOOKED AT OUR ROLES
AND FIFTY PERCENT OF OUR CALPERS
ADULTS DON'T HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA.
AND READ THEM SEE THIS CONTINUE
WE WANT TO GET THE YOUNGER
GENERATION TO TRY TO
INCENTIVIZE.
THEM CONTINUING SCHOOL AND
GRADUATE OF MY SCHOOL AND
HOPEFULLY GOING ON TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
UP THROUGH THE TWO YEARS HE
OPERATE THIS PROBABLY TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN. OF
WE HAVE HAD.
.
STUDENTS WHO'VE COMPLETED THAT
PARTLY OVER TWO THOUSAND THIS
PAST YEAR AND AND I THOUGHT BY
TWO THOUSAND YOU BEFORE.
OUT OF THOSE STUDENTS.
A OVER FIFTY PERCENT HAVE BOUGHT
A HIGHER EDUCATION.
THEY HAVE REALLY YOU KNOW HELP
WEEKS THAT MARKET BUT VENTURA
SETTING WITH ASHLEY TWENTY
PERCENT WANTED TO FOUR
UNIVERSITIES
SO IT IS REALLY.
MOTIVATIONAL FOR US MEANS A LOT
TO US AND OUR FAMILIES AND
THAT'S WHAT REACH A COUPLE OF
QUOTES Y. FAMILIES.
.
ONE AT YOUTH SAID.
WHICH A GRADUATE THIS WAS IN
JUNE OF LAST YEAR. AND SHE
BELIEVE UNIVERSITY AND SHE'S
USING THE MONEY TO BUY LAPTOP
FOR COLLEGE CAREER.
SO EXHIBIT BY REDUCING A LOT BUT
THAT MADE A DIFFERENCE TO HER
LAPTOP IN COLLEGES SUB UNIT MUST
HAVE THESE DAYS.
ANOTHER PAIR CHAIR BUT THAT'S
THAT HER SON HAD A CHANCE TO
PRESENT A PROGRAM AND IT
MOTIVATED HIM TO CONTINUE SCHOOL
KNOWING THAT THAT THE SENATE WAS
THEY ARE.
SO HE STAYED IN SCHOOL HE WAS
THE MONEY HE MIGHT APPEAR AS
WELL EXACTLY STEADY INCOME
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS.
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER WHO HAVE.
SOME THAT OP MOM IF SHE SAID THE
PROBLEM IS REALLY GREAT IS A
GREAT RELIEF FINANCIALLY FOR THE
PARENTS AND THE STUDENTS.
I. THEIR DAUGHTER USED THEIR
MONEY TO PURCHASE BOOKS FOR
COLLEGE.
AND SHE'S REALLY ENCOURAGING.
THAT WE CONTINUE THE PROGRAM.
BECAUSE SHE HAS AIDS ANOTHER
CHILD THE WINGS IS WAITING FOR
HIS TURN.
SO THAT AB YOU KNOW WHAT WE SAVE
FOR THAT AND THAT MOST OF THE
KIDS. BABU CLOSE TO SIXTY
PERCENT ARE USING THE MONEY FOR.
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BOB MADAM CHAIR MICRO WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ IN THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION A SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THINKING.
ANYWAY THIS IS AN OPPOSITION.
K. HEARING AND ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO.
AS I NEVER COME ADDITION TO DUE
PROCESS TO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES VETERAN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
REPEAL AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE BUT I'M GONNA.
BUT I'M GLAD I MAIENSCHEIN.
GRASS.
THERE'S AYE STONE.
THURMOND.
THIS BILL
ZERO OUT.
THANK YOU.
K. I I SEE MISTER GARCIA.
HERE.
I'M SORRY YEAH I'M SORRY.
IF THE OUT THE VOTERS FOUR ZERO
WILL LEAVE IT UP OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO. ADD ON BUT IT IS OUT
AS OF NOW.
IT'S A PRETTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I. GONNA STILL LINE
FROM THE GENTLEMAN WHO TALKED
ABOUT POVERTY IS THE.
PARENT OF CRIME.
AND I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT.
CHILDREN OF INCARCERATED
PARENTS.
IN THE ENVIRONMENT THAT THEY'RE
BEING RAISED.
POTENTIALLY CONTINUES TO
PERPETUATE THAT CYCLE OF POVERTY
HERE.
AB THREE ZERO ZERO SEVEN ALLOWS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
TO ESTABLISH A COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM OF SUPPORT SERVICES
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS.
OF CHILDREN INCARCERATED.
OF INCARCERATED PARENTS I
RESPECT YES THROUGHOUT BOTH WE
ARE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I THINK IT MAKES THE
BILL. MUCH MORE CLEAR TENS OF
OUR INTENTION AND AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL THANK
YOU ANYWAY BUSINESS AND SUPPORT.
LOW.
AND ONE WELL I DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND ALRIGHT.
I'M ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
REPRESENTING THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
.
EXCUSE US WE RAN IN THERE YUBA
COUNTY RIVERSIDE THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL OUT WE THINK A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA SO MUCH FOR.
TAKING UP THIS POLICY PRIORITY I
THINK THIS COMMITTEE CERTAINLY.
UNDERSTANDS.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH PRINT TO
INCARCERATION HAD CREATES VERY
PROFOUND.
EXPERIENCES FOR THOSE CHILDREN
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS
IDENTIFIED CREATING A SUPPORT
SET OF SUPPORTIVE SERVICES UP.
FOR THIS GROUP OF YOUTH
OF WE APPRECIATE HIS SUPPORT I
AM GOING TO INTRODUCE
CAITLYN STORM WHO IS WITH THE
COUNTY AND YOU CAN PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THE
PROGRAM THINK THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CAITLYN STORM AND I WORK AS
AN ANALYST IN THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICE RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
WITH THE ISSUE OF OVERCROWDING
OUR LOCAL JAILS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM REFORM. HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS A POLICY PARTY FOR
THE COUNTY.
FURTHER RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
CHILDREN CURSORY TO PARENTS
WHICH I'LL REFER TO AS CIP.
EXPRESS PARTICULAR VULNERABILITY
TO BECOME INCARCERATED COMPARED
TO PURSUE NOT HAVE INCARCERATED
PARENTS.
AS A RESULT MY COLLEAGUE FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRIGHTNESS INDIAN
I HAVE DEVELOPED A PROGRAM TO
REDUCE TRAUMA INDUCED RESILIENCY
IN THE CIP POPULATION. IN ORDER
TO REDUCE HE NEGATIVE OUTCOMES
THEY OFTEN EXPERIENCE
INCLUDING AN INCREASE
SUSCEPTIBILITY TO FUTURE
INCARCERATION AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT.
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICE BEGIN EXPLORING THE IDEA.
OF A SOCIAL IMPACT BOND AS A
MEANS TO DESIGN AND FUND
PROGRAMS.
IN MAY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
WE APPLIED IN A PERSIMMON
APPLICATION TO NATIONWIDE
COMPETITION OUTLINING OUR IDEA
FOR WRAPAROUND SERVICES PROGRAM
FOR CIP.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND THE YALE
CHILD CENTER STUDY WERE SELECTED
AS THE TO A WORD THESE
TO RECEIVE TECHNICAL SERVICES
ASSISTANCE FROM SOCIAL FINANCE
INC.
AND TOWARDS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AMERICANS RECORD.
WHICH IS ONE VARIATION OF THE
SOCIAL IMPACT BOND.
SINCE THEN WE HAVE BEEN
THOUGHTFULLY DESIGNING A PROGRAM
USING A TWO GENERATIONAL
HOLISTIC HEALTH APPROACH.
THAT WILL PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
EVIDENCE BASED RESOURCES AND
SERVICES THAT HAVE PROVEN TO
POSITIVELY IMPACT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
WE HAVE FOUND THAT TO TRULY
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR CIP. WE
NEED TO ADDRESS MULTIPLE AREAS
OF HEALTH
AS OUTLINED IN AB THREE ZERO
ZERO SEVEN.
THESE INCLUDE PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL
MENTAL AN OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
AND SOCIAL.
ADDITIONALLY.
ACTUALLY MAKE A POSITIVE AND
LASTING IMPACT IN THE LIVES OF
THESE CHILDREN WE NEED TO
CONNECT THEIR CARETAKERS TO
RESOURCES AND SERVICES THAT
REDUCE STRESS AND IMPROVE
STABILITY.
OUR GOAL AND EXPECTATION IS THAT
THE CAP PROGRAM WILL PRODUCE A
NUMBER OF POSITIVE OUTCOMES.
JUST INCREASED POSITIVE PARENT
CHILD INTERACTION. REDUCE
ANXIETY DEPRESSION AND PTSD
SYMPTOMS AMONG AFFECTED
CHILDREN.
AS WELL AS ENHANCED HOME.
M. SAFETY AND PARENTAL
SUPERVISION AMONG OTHERS.
OUR HOPE IS THAT WITH POSITIVE
INTERVENTIONS WE CAN STRENGTHEN
THE RESILIENCY OF THIS PHONE OF
A POPULATION. HELP THEM ACHIEVE
LONG TERM SUCCESS AND WELL BEING
AND PLACE THEM ON A POSITRON
AWAY FROM INCARCERATION.
WE HOPE THIS PROGRAM WILL SERVE
AS A MODEL FOR OTHER COUNTIES
STATES AND COUNTRIES THAT THE
NEEDS OF CIP ARE BETTER
UNDERSTOOD AND ADDRESSED.
I WISH TO EXPRESS MY SINCERE
APPRECIATION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA FOR AUTHORING THIS
MEASURE. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE COMMITTEES A VOTE I VOTE ON
AP THREE ZERO ZERO SEVEN.
THANK YOU KNOW ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
K. HEARING NONE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
TO IT IS THE CUTTING EDGE OF
RESEARCH FOR US TO IDENTIFY. THE
TRAUMA THAT OUR KIDS ARE GOING
THROUGH AND THIS PROGRAM MAYBE
THE EXAMPLE FOR THE REST OF OUR
STATE TO FOLLOW AND. SO THANK
YOU SIR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING IT TODAY. THANK YOU
AND THE OTHER MEMBERS.
THIS RAISES.
I DO HAVE A COMPLAINT.
.
THAT IT'S ONLY RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND SANDRA DINO NOT INCLUDED NO.
SO HOPEFULLY SOMETHING LIKE THIS
ONCE WE SEE THE GREAT SUCCESS IN
SUCH A PROGRAM THAT CAN BE
EXPANDED.
TWO OTHER COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
AND A RECOMMENDATION TO THE.
AS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. ARM CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
NUMBER LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S.
PRESS AYE STONE.
BERMAN.
BILLS OF DOT ISSUE BILL AS A
FOUR ZERO VOTE AT MOVES ON TO
THE. ASSEMBLY FLOOR. THANK YOU.
A ASSEMBLYMAN RICHARD
.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SAN A
MEMBERS I'D JUST LIKE TO START
OUT BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE'S
A STAFF AND THE DAM. CHAIR TO
WORK WITH MY STAFF FOR THE.
A AMENDMENT OF.
DEFINITELY BE HAPPY TO
ACCEPTING THE COMEY HE'S FOR
AMENDMENT. AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT REQUIRED ALL CONTINUING
CARE RETIREMENT COMMUNITY.
INCLUDING BILLS AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. TO STUDY.
OF BIG FINANCIAL RISK SUCH AS
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COSTS.
INDIRA FACILITY TO BETTER PLANE
PLAN FOR THAT EARNED HIM.
BEING IN IMPENDING COST AND
LIMITED FINANCIAL IMPACT TO DO
RESIDENTS.
THE REQUIREMENT IN MY BILL IS
DIFFERENT AND THE CURRENT
FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE STATEMENT A
DISK DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS.
AND I JUST GO TO A LOT OF IT
DEEPER INTO MORE FACTORS.
A DEBT COULD POSE FINANCIAL
RISKS
TO FAILURE A POTENTIAL
RESIDENTS.
DOES LIVING IN THE C. C. R. C.
HAVE PUT UP A LOT OF EFFORT INTO
PLANNING FOR THEIR RETIREMENT.
AND TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY FOR DEER.
LATER YEARS
WELL I'M FACILITY OWNER NOT
PLAYING FOR.
DO NOT PLAN FOR FUTURE
MAINTENANCE COSTS SUCH AS
FILLING EQUIPMENT AND OR A LEAKY
MOVE FOR AND AND AND THEY PUT IT
RESIDENTS AT RISK.
OF MONTHLY FEE INCREASES WHEN
REPAIR OR REPLACEMENT NEED TO
HAPPEN.
IT IS.
GENERALLY CHEAPER TO ADDRESS
THOSE MAINTENANCE ISSUE.
EARLIER.
OWN DREADED IN A LATER.
SO THIS BILL WILL.
REQUIRED THEM TO A HOW TO OF
MORE REGULAR CHECKUPS EVERY FIVE
YEARS.
AND TO TO HAVE A BETTER.
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE BILL FUTURE
OF POTENTIAL OF CULTURAL PER
REQUIREMENT.
AM I MY MY BILL PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND ALSO PROMOTE GOOD
BUSINESS PRACTICE.
IN TO ATTEMPTED. THIS AFTERNOON
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS WHOM MORE
THAN COVER HALL AND MARGARET
GRIFFIN'S REPRESENING CALL THE
FUNNIER CONTINUING CARE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION.
NO TO SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M MARGARET CRESSMAN PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA CONTINUING
CARE RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION OR
CAL CRA.
AND A RESIDENT OF UNIVERSITY
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY CCRC IN
DAVIS.
CALPERS THE SOUL ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING SENIORS LIVING IN
C. C. R. SEASON CALIFORNIA. OUR
MISSION IS TO ENHANCE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND FINANCIAL
SECURITY OF CCRC RESIDENTS. AND
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT.
C. C. R. C.'S OFFER RESIDENTS A
CONTINUUM OF CARE FROM
INDEPENDENT LIVING THROUGH
ASSISTED LIVING. USUALLY ALSO
DEMENTIA CARE AND FINALLY
SKILLED NURSING.
RESIDENTS PAY BOTH AN ENTRANCE
FEE TO MOVE INTO A CCRC AND THEN
AN ONGOING MONTHLY FEE. WHICH IS
SUBJECT TO INCREASES AT THE
DISCRETION OF OUR PROVIDER.
THESE FEES COVER EVERYTHING FROM
MANAGEMENT CARE AND SERVICES
THROUGH MAINTENANCE AND UPKEEP
OF THE FACILITY.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT
ACTUARIAL STUDIES BE OBTAINED
EVERY FIVE YEARS BUT ONLY BY C.
C. R. C.'S THAT OFFER TYPE A OR
LIFE CARE CONTRACTS.
WHICH ACCOUNT FOR ONLY TENOF
THE OVER ONE HUNDRED CC OUR
SEASON CALIFORNIA.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATISTICAL
MODELING IN FINANCIAL RISK
ASSESSMENT ANALYSES PROVIDED BY
AN ACTUARY. ARE VALUABLE TOOLS
IT SHOULD BE UTILIZED BY ALL C.
C. R. C.'S IN THEIR LONG TERM
PLANNING. REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE
OF CONTRACT THEY OFFER.
ACTUARIAL STUDIES GENERATE DATA
THAT QUANTIFIES LONG TERM
LIABILITIES AND IDENTIFIES
OPTIONS FOR MEETING THEM.
IT ALSO PROVIDES INFORMATION
RELATIVE TO THE ABILITY TO MEET
FUTURE CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS
AND TO SET PRICES.
FOR SHORT AND LONG TERM HOUSING
AND CARE OPTIONS.
WITHOUT AN ACTUARIAL STUDY.
A CCRC MAY APPEAR FINANCIALLY
STABLE IN THE SHORT TERM. YET
STILL FACE SIGNIFICANT THREATS
TO ITS LONG TERM VIABILITY.
WHO CAN YOU WRAP UP PLEASE JUST
AS ACTUARIAL STUDIES FOCUS ON
THE BUSINESS SIDE OF AN
OPERATION THERE IS ALSO A NEED
TO ADDRESS THE PHYSICAL PLANT
AND EQUIPMENT OF THE FACILITY?
IGNORING OR DEFERRING
MAINTENANCE ISSUES GUARANTEES
THAT NGUYEN FINALLY DISCOVERED
THE EVENTUAL REPAIRERS WILL ONLY
BE MORE SEVERE AND EXPENSIVE.
THEREFORE IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
CCRC USE.
REGULARLY OBTAINED A MAINTENANCE
AND REPAIR REVIEW OF THEIR
IMPORTANT BUILDING SYSTEMS.
THE FINANCIAL BURDEN OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND POOR PLANNING
FALLS ON THE SHOULDERS OF
RESIDENTS IN THE FORM OF FEE
INCREASES.
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN WOULD HAVE
BEEN REQUIRED HAD THESE ISSUES
BEEN PROMPTLY IDENTIFIED AND
DEALT WITH.
HAVING THE INFORMATION.
PROVIDED BY THESE LONG TERM
PLANNING TOOLS WILL ALLOW
MANAGEMENT TO BE MORE FULLY
AWARE. OF THE STRENGTHS AND
WEAKNESSES OF THEIR CCRC AS A
WHOLE.
AND TO BE MORE PROACTIVE AND
EFFECTIVE IN ALLOCATING
RESOURCES TO MEET THOSE NEEDS.
ENSURING THAT BOTH BUSINESS AND
THE PHYSICAL PLANT ARE SOUND.
HELPS BOTH MANAGEMENT AND
PRESIDENT'S MANAGE THE COSTS
INVOLVED. IN IT ENSURES THE
PROTECTION OF THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS RESIDENTS HAVE MADE
IN THEIR CCR SCENES.
THAT IS WHY A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT IS SO IMPORTANT TO US.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
WIENER CHAIR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MORTON CARB
ALTERNATIVE STRATEGY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF CAL CROWDS WELL IT ALL
JUST BE BRIEF AND I THINK THE
CONSULTANT FOR A VERY THOROUGH
ANALYSIS ON THIS BILL IN JUST
ONE UPON ADD TWO POINTS.
ON THE NOTION THAT CCRC
PROVIDERS THAT DON'T OFFER
TAIPEI CONTRACTS DON'T SHARE THE
SAME RISK AS OTHER CCRC
PROVIDERS. I LIKE TO BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT ALL THESE YEARS HE'S
MAKE THE SAME UNDERLYING PROMISE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT TYPE OF
CONTRACT THE OFFER. TO
ACCOMMODATE RESIDENTS AS THEIR
HEALTHCARE NEEDS CHANGE.
ALL CCRC IS MAINTAIN INDEPENDENT
LIVING ESOS ASSISTED LIVING AND
SKILLED NURSING UNITS ON CAMPUS
AND ALSO USE YOUR SEATS PROMISE
TO ACCOMMODATE THE RESIDENTS AS
THEY AGE. ALL CCRC SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO USE STRATEGIC
PLANNING TOOLS THAT HELP TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN UPLOAD THE
PROMISES THAT THEY'VE MADE TO
THE RESIDENTS I'M HERE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES THE SUPPORT.
I AM A RESIDENT OF CCRC IN
DAVIS.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STUART GROHMAN I AM A
RESIDENT OF A CCRC. IN
CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO A RESIDENT.
A REPRESENTATIVE OF RESIDENTS
THERE AND WE ARE IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL. EVEN THOUGH WE WISHED
THAT THE.
REPLACEMENT.
AND.
REPAIR STUDY WOULD INCLUDING
FINANCIAL.
RESERVE FOR THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
NAME IS ROBERT SWENSON.
I'M A RESIDENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY RETIREMENT COMMUNITY.
AND DAVIS.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
I'M WHILE HOGAN LIVE AT THE
ESCHATON VILLAGE CARMICHAEL
ALONG WITH FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
OTHER SENIORS.
OUR OWNER PROVIDER DOES NONE OF
THE THINGS CURRENTLY.
HER REQUIRED BY THIS BILL. AS A
RESULT MAINTENANCE AND
REPLACEMENT IS INADEQUATE WE
NEED THESE PROVISIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I'M DAVID PREDATOR I'M A
RESIDENT OF CCRC AND DAVIS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M PRESCOTT WILLIAMS PRESIDENT
OF.
CCRC IN DAVIS I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
DAPHNE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
JET HAMPTON ON BEHALF OF
LEADING EDGE CALIFORNIA OUT
ROUTE REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
TODAY I FIRST AND FOREMOST I
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS
FOR.
WILLING TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THINK
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE SIGNIFICANT WORK
THAT THEY.
PUT INTO THE ANALYSIS OF THE OF
THE BILL.
.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
AGAIN LEADING EDGE CALIFORNIA
IS A. ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
REPRESENTS NOT FOR PROFIT A
SENIOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING CARE
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS TO AT THE
STATE.
WE HAVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WITH THE SIGNIFICANT OUT
COMPONENT OUR MEMBERSHIP MADE UP
OF NOT FOR PROFIT C. C. R. C.'S.
AGAIN A PORTION WE ARE RIDLEY
POSTS THE BILL.
.
AS IT AS IT CURRENTLY IS UP
PRIMARILY BECAUSE WE DO THINK
THAT THE THE PROVISION TO HAVE
NATURAL STUDY THROUGH ALL SIX
YEARS SEE TYPES IS UNNECESSARY.
AND UNDULY EXPENSIVE FOR.
CCRC THAT DO NOT PROVIDE THAT I
DON'T HAVE THE SAME FINANCIAL
OBLIGATION FINANCIAL RISK.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
TO TO DELINEATE BETWEEN THE TIE
CONTRACT TYPES WHO WERE
DISCUSSING C. C. R. C.'S.
.
PRIMARILY AT THE TYPE A CONTRACT
ARE NOT ONLY INCLUDE THE HIGHER
ENTRANCE FEE WITH HIGHER MONTHLY
FEES.
BUT THESE FEES CANNOT BE
MODIFIED SIGNIFICANTLY ON A ON A
YEAR TO YEAR BASIS.
FURTHERMORE THE CCRC IS
OBLIGATED TO TAKE CARE OF THAT
INDIVIDUAL FOR LIFE REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THEY OUT SPEND.
THEIR EXISTING RESOURCES
INCLUDING THEIR ENTRANCE FEE AND
A MONTHLY FEES. SO FOR INSTANCE
IF IF A RESIDENT AT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM CARE NEEDS
NEEDED.
MAXIM HEALTHCARE SERVICES AT
THE CCRC.
ROOM REGARDLESS IF THEY HAD THE
ABILITY TO PAY OR MEET THE
MONTHLY FEE OBLIGATION THE CCRC
IS STILL RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
CARE FOR THE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL.
THIS IS WHY CURRENTLY.
TYPE ES CONTRACTS REQUIRE
NATURAL STATE BECAUSE THAT THE
RISK BORN BY THE CCRC. IS MUCH
MORE SIGNIFICANT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT TAIPEI CONTRACT.
THE OTHER CONTRACT TYPES
INCLUDING TYPE B. AND TYPE C.
CONTRACTS ARE MODIFIED VERSIONS
OF A CONTRACT TYPE.
WHERE IN INFANCY IS STILL PAID
AND MONTHLY FEES ARE STILL PAID
TYPICALLY HAVE A LOWER RATE BUT
THESE MONTHLY FEES CAN BE
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY?
SHOULD THE INDIVIDUAL NEED
ACCESS TO ADDITIONAL HEALTHCARE
COSTS.
SO.
YOU KNOW WE WE WE CERTAINLY
FEEL THAT THAT.
REQUIRING CCRC TO.
CONDUCT NATURAL STUDY WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE.
A SIGNIFICANT RISK AND THAT TYPE
A CONTRACT DOES IS UNNECESSARY
IS EXPENSIVE AND.
VERY LIKELY THOSE COSTS WILL BE
PASSED ONTO THE RESIDENTS ARE
JUST A MINUTE OR COMMUNITIES
LIKE TO AVOID SELF.
I HOPE THAT BEING SAID I AM WE
ARE UNFORTUNATE OPPOSITION THINK
IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS HEATHER HARRISON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM LIVING
ASSOCIATION WE PRO REPRESENTS. A
CONTINUING CARE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS.
OF MY COLLEAGUE I I WON'T BE
REPETITIVE.
BUT I DO WANT TO STRESS A
COUPLE POINTS ITS ITS THE NATURE
OF THE THAT TYPE A CONTRACT THAT
WARRANTS THE ACTUARIAL STUDY
THAT'S WHY THE LEGISLATURE. AND
THE STATE HAS SET THE SYSTEM UP
TO FOCUS ON THAT THE OTHER
CONTRACT TYPES DON'T CARRY THAT
SAME TYPE OF.
OF RISK THAT THE ACTUARIES
STUDY WHEN THEY DO THOSE KINDS
OF REPORTS.
THE FINANCIAL ASPECTS OF C. C.
R. C.'S ARE ALL READY HIGHLY
REGULATED THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TRANSPARENCY. WITH.
AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
AND KEY INDICATOR REPORTS
REPORTED ANNUALLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND ARE AVAILABLE ON THE STATE'S
WEBSITE ARE AVAILABLE TO
RESIDENTS.
DSS REVIEWS THAT INFORMATION AND
IF THERE IS.
CAUSE FOR CONCERN THEY TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION AND DSS IS
DOING ITS JOB.
WE APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND.
THE ALL THE WORK THAT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS DIED
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY DO NOT
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION.
.
THE THE MAINTENANCE AND RUB ON
REPAIR REVIEW.
IT AGAIN APPRECIATE THE SOME OF
THAT THE CHANGES IN THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD BUT THE.
.
THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION IS
ALREADY AVAILABLE.
MUCH OF IT THE ISSUE COMES UP
DURING THE BUDGETING PROCESS
IN IN CONVERSATIONS RESIDENTS
ARE ENCOURAGED DURING THAT
BUDGET PROCESS TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THESE
COMMUNITIES ABOUT.
ABOUT THEIR HOME WHERE THEY
LIVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO THE
PROVIDERS AS WELL THAT THEY HAVE
A GOOD EXPERIENCE AND THAT THE
FINANCIAL HEALTH AND THE.
UPKEEP IS PROVIDED WE DON'T SEE
THIS BILL.
.
UP REALLY ENHANCING THAT PROCESS
SO I'M FOR THOSE REASONS WE
REMAIN OPPOSED.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER UP WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
K. HEARING NONE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CHOI.
AND THANK YOU ARE THROUGHOUT THE
EMPHASIS OF VARIOUS SENSITIVE LA
NOW QUESTIONS OF THAT THOUGH YOU
ARE PRESENTING.
.
AS WE HAVE FACED SO MANY PEOPLE
WHO WOULD THAT RELY ON OUR.
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES SAID
THIS ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
.
WITH THE CURRENT CONDITION.
WHAT THE?
?
WITHOUT THIS A CORRECTIVE
MEASURE.
.
WAS THERE ANY BIG PROBLEM.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE QUESTION.
NUMBER TWO HOW MUCH DOES IT COST
THE ACTUARIAL STUDY IS SALVO I'M
SURE THE SO WHAT COSTLY IS TO
NOT EVERY YEAR BUT THE ONCE IN
THIRTY YEARS THAT THE SO SOUND
SO REASONABLE WHEN I LISTEN TO
YOU.
BUT WHEN I LISTEN TO OPPOSITION.
I MEAN AND YOU ARE BUDGET THE
PRESENTATION WILL TAKE CARE OF
AND THEN ALSO.
THE OWNERS OR OPERATORS SELF
THAT FACILITY.
WELL TYPICALLY. IN A RESERVE US
SOME FUN STUFF FOR MAINTENANCE
FUNDS ETCETERA.
SO WHY DO WE HAVE TO OVER
REGULATE.
YOU KNOW THEIR OWN PROPERTY.
IT'S SORT OTHER SORTS OF COOPER
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE.
A GOOD THING THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THE AYE YOU WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER.
TWO YOU OR HOW MUCH OF A COST TO
DO THE ACTUAL RE STUDY. BUT
QUITE I CAN.
TO SHARE WITH YOU WHAT THE
ADDITIONAL COST OF THIS BILL.
IS PRETTY MUCH ASKED
THE.
DO YOU DO OWNER TO DO A LOT
LIKE I. REALLY GOOD GENERAL
INSPECTION OF THE BUILDING TO
ASSESS DO.
THE DAVID COULD DO TO REMOVING
CONDITION OR SOME MAJOR
EQUIPMENT AND IT'S AN EIGHTY
HEHE AIR CONDITIONING AND SO ON
AND SO FORTH. AND SO.
BUT I DON'T THINK WORK AT EVERY
FIVE YEARS.
AND YOU WOULD REALLY.
I DON'T BELIEVE WHAT AT ANY
ADDITIONAL COSTS TO WHAT'S
ALREADY.
.
MANDATED BY THE STATE LAW.
IF FIVE I COULD JUST ADD AS
WELL-AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND. ON
THE
POINT OF THE.
THE COST WITH THE BILL DISS AND
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE
ACCEPTED IT SPREADS THOSE COSTS
OUT OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD SO.
SPREADING THAT CAUSE OUT OVER A
FIVE YEAR PERIOD WE ANTICIPATE
THAT ANY COST TO THE RESIDENTS
WOULD BE NOMINAL.
.
DOES THAT AS IT WOULD KINDA WORK
OUT IN THE BUDGET AND. JUST ONE
POINT TO THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
ANNUAL BUDGETS AND HOW THAT THAT
LOOKS AT THE.
THE FINANCES OF THE FACILITY.
I THINK THESE ARE TWO KIND OF
SEPARATE THINGS ANNUAL BUDGETS
AND AUDITS LOOK AT. THE FORMER
FOR THE FORMAL FIND ARE THE YEAR
BEHIND US RIGHT THEY LOOK AT HOW
WE DID THIS YEAR HOW THE
FINANCES LOOKED.
YOU KNOW WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT
NOW AN ACTUARIAL STUDIES ARE
FORWARD THINKING AND THEY LOOK
AT PROJECTIONS OF.
POPULATION PROJECTIONS COST
PROJECTIONS ON.
BECAUSE SEVERAL OTHER THINGS
THAT HELP ANALYZE THE FORWARD
LIABILITY THE FORD FINANCIAL
LIABILITIES THAT THEY'VE CCRC
MAC MIGHT FACE DOWN THE ROAD.
THOSE THOSE RISKS ARE WAY.
INHERENTLY WINDOWS HEAD IF THE
CCRC ISN'T PLANNING AHEAD FOR
THOSE KIND OF THINGS. THE HEAD
OF THAT IS FINE IS A FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON THE RESIDENTS BECAUSE
AS WE KNOW. THE RESIDENTS THERE
AT THEIR MONTHLY FEES CAN
INCREASE BASED ON OPERATION
COSTS INCREASE IN OTHER
INCREASES THAT SYNTHESISER
PROVIDER. HAS AND IF THEY HAVE
AN ANTICIPATED THOSE THEN THAT
INCREASED MAY FALL ON THE
RESIDENTS SO WE SEE THAT THE
FINANCIAL BENEFITS ABOUT FAR
OUTWEIGHING. ON ANY NOMINAL COST
THAT THE ACTUARIAL STUDY WOULD
WOULD HAVE ON THAT RESIDENTS.
SOME FINAL QUESTIONS ARE.
A LONG TIME AGO WAS OPEN UPON A
TIME I SERVED AS A. THOSE SMALL
LOW HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION BOARD
MEMBER.
OF THOSE ARE ALWAYS TO ANNUAL.
AND A MANAGEMENT COMPANY GIVEN
MONTHLY THAT REPORT COCA.
AND THAT THEY UP COMMONSENSE A
INCLUDED DATA.
HE OUT REPLACEMENT COST AND THE
RESERVATIONS. AND THE.
THE STREET OF A READ PAVEMENT
DATA ETCETERA ETCETERA.
SEWER ANY A AND T. WHY THEY
WOULD NOT THE INCLUDE PROJECT
THAT THE STATE HAVE TO BE
COSTLY.
SOUNDTRACKER ACTUARIAL STUDY
SALVO.
I DON'T KNOW PROBABLY AND THE
LIST SUPPORT SO IT IT.
IT HAS SAY SOMEONE VALUE ONCE
YOU SUBMIT TO DR SOCIAL SERVICE
DEPARTMENT THE. WORD SOMEBODY
STUDY AND THEY. AND A AND ARE
THERE HAS TO BE SOMEBODY STUDY
THAT FACTORY OR STUDIES OUT OF.
AND DOES SOME SOME PROBLEMATIC
ISSUE FOUND THE. OF IN THAT
STUDY SOMEONE HAS TO FOLLOW UP.
P. ACCORDING TO YOUR REPORT THAT
THIS IS NOT SUFFICIENT ON YOUR
BODY THAT.
THE.
DO YOU HAVE A SUCH A MECHANISM
SO THAT'LL BE AMADOR INCREASE
OUT OF OUR.
AT JUST OF FOR DOING IT THIS OUT
FOR I MEAN.
IT HAS TO HAVE IT HAS TO COST
SOME ACTION FROM THAT STUDY.
IF I HAD RECEIVED A STAR ACT
OREOS ACTIVITY JUSTIFY LIT
WALKED Y. SOMEBODY HAS TO STUDY.
AND THE COME UP WITH THE HEY YOU
PASS.
NO URINE PASS IN SOME FOLLOW UP
ACTION.
GOOD IF I IF I MAJOR THE SO THAT
ACTUARIAL STUDY WOULD BE
PROVIDED ONCE IT WAS FINISHED BY
THE ACTUARY PROVIDED TO THAT
PROVIDERS BUT IT WOULD BE GIVEN
TO THE PROVIDERS BOARD AND THAT
BODY WOULD BE ABLE TO ANALYZE
THAT AND LOOK OUT AND.
AND USE THOSE PROJECTIONS IN
THEIR IN THEIR BUDGETING AND IN
THEIR DECISION MAKING MOVING
FORWARD AS THE CCRC BOARD.
A SO SO THAT MINNESOTA IN
ADDITION TO THE OPERATORS SO
ADDITIONAL COST TO PUT A STUDY.
BUT THE SORT OF SERVICE
DEPARTMENT ITSELF FOR
MONITORING.
WOULD HAVE TO INCREASE.
IT'S NOW AND THE FOLLOW UP
ACTIONS SO HAVE YOU THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT THE COST OF THE
SOCIAL DEPARTMENTS SOCIAL
SERVICE DEPARTMENT OPERATION
COST HOW MUCH DATA COOPER.
SO THE BOARD RIGHT NOW RECEIVES
THESE REPORTS THE ACTUARIAL
STUDIES FROM ANY CCRC THE OFFERS
THAT TYPE A CONTRACT TO THEIR
ALREADY REQUIRED TO DO ACTUARIAL
STUDIES. SO THIS WOULD JUST FALL
IN THAT SAME LINE IN THE SENSE
THAT LOOK AT THOSE ANNUAL
REPORTS IN
THE FILE THEM. THERE'S NO.
THERE'S NO PASS OR FAIL AYE AYE
GUESSES BUT A GOOD WAY OF
DESCRIBING THAT THE IF THE. THE
DEPARTMENT DOES A PASS OR FAIL A
CCRC BASED ON WHAT THE ACTUARIAL
STUDY.
STUDY COMES BACK WITH.
IT'S JUST THAT IT'S A TOOL THAT
THE CCRC COULD USE IN THEIR
FUTURE PLANNING AND AND AND AND
THEY'RE PLANNING IN OUTLOOK.
AS THEY LOOKED. BUDGETS DOWN
THE ROAD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OKAY THANK YOU I HAVE A MOTION A
BY DR ARAMBULA AND THE SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS AND THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO AGING AND LONG TERM
CARE. CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
ON NOT VOTING DUCKS CHOI NOT
VOTING ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
FRANCE.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
WHAT IS YOUR QUE THE BILL'S OUT
AND IT'S ALL GOING TO AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE THANK YOU? YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON.
START OFF BY THINKING OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK IN
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HAS CLAIMED
COUNTLESS LIVES IT'S BEEN AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
IN THIS BUILDING FOR. A COUPLE
YEARS NOW.
WE WEREN'T MAKING MUCH OF A
DENT YET AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S MILLIONS OF KIDS OUT
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A
STATE HAS COMMITTED.
.
AND ONE IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE NOW IS WE'VE WE
DECRIMINALIZE IT WOULD SAY THAT
THAT KIDS CAN'T BE THAT HARD
WITH THE CRIME IF THEY'RE UNDER.
EIGHTEEN WHICH WE ALL AGREE WITH
BUT AT THE SAME TIME. WHAT WE
PROVIDING FOR THESE KIDS AND IT
IS ONE THING TO BE ABLE TO SAVE
SOMEBODY FROM A REALLY BAD HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SITUATION? BUT IF WE
DON'T HAVE REALLY GOOD SERVICES
THAN TO TREAT THEM WHEN THEY
COME OUT THESE ARE. KIDS
SOMETIMES OF BRAINS LOOK LIKE
THEY'VE BEEN IN A WAR ZONE
BECAUSE OF THE MULTIPLE TRAUMA
IS THAT THEY'VE ENCOUNTERED
SOMETIMES FROM MULTIPLE YEARS.
AND SO WHAT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
THAT COUNTIES ARE DOING IT IN
DIFFERENT KINDS OF FASHIONS.
DOM WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT SOME
ARE MORE EFFECTIVE THAN OTHERS A
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A A COMMON WAY
TO COLLECT THAT DATA AND BE ABLE
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT AND HOW DO WE DO USE
BEST. A PRACTICES.
SO THIS SIMPLY SAYS THAT THE A
NDSS DID A STUDY LAST YEAR THAT
KIND OF SENT OVER THERE SOME
THERE SOME GAPS HERE AND THERE
AND AROUND.
TO THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS THAT
THEY WILL DO A REPORT TO US THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN A BEST
PRACTICES WATER DIFFERENT
COUNTIES DOING. AND AND AND WHAT
MORE DO WE NEED TO DO.
WITH ME HERE TODAY I HAVE ED
HOWARD A WITH THE CHILD
ADVOCACY.
THANK YOU.
MOTION BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA
SECOND BY A SOME NUMBER YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AT HOWARD SENIOR COUNSEL
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
SCHOOL OF LAW I WANNA ECHO. OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND EXPRESS
GRATITUDE TO YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF WHICH REALLY LEARNED
VALUABLE IN HELPING SHAPE THIS
BILL. ON AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAID ON AND IS DOCUMENTED A
CORRECTLY ON PAGE FIVE OF YOUR A
REALLY EXCELLENT ANALYSIS WE'VE
GOT A LONG WAY TO GO.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE BOTH
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL AND STATE
LAW WHEN PROVIDING SERVICES FOR
THESE GIRLS.
BUT ALSO COMPLY WITH OUR MORAL
OBLIGATION TO OFFER THEM AND
PROVIDE THEM THE SERVICES THEY
SO.
THAT DESPERATELY NEED A IN LIGHT
OF THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
DOCUMENTED LONG WAY TO GO THE
APPROACH TAKEN BY THIS BILL IS A
MEASURE ONE.
IT SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE BE KEPT ABREAST OF
COUNTY PROGRESS.
A IN MEETING.
THE GOALS SET OUT IN FEDERAL
LAW AND STATE LAW. AYE AND
ENCOURAGES COUNTIES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
IDENTIFY AND IMPLEMENT.
BEST PRACTICES BY A DATE
CERTAIN.
OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE MOST
TRAGIC POPULATIONS IN OUR STATE
THEY DESERVE OUR ATTENTION.
AND SUPPORT AND ON THEIR BEHALF
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF.
THANK YOU ANY OF THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IT ME WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A HEARING AND I'LL BRING IT BACK
UP TO THE DICE AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY HEARING NONE. OF WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES.
THANK YOU WITH ALLOCATED MONEY
TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS KIND OF
WORK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND I I HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. ON KING OLIVER
PLEASE.
DOCTOR CHOI HIGH.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
STONE.
THURMAN'S.
OKAY.
THE BILL WITHOUT FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU.
MISTER GIBSON.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT
WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT YOU CAN
FOSTER CARE AND YOUTH AND LOCAL
JUVENILE OUT.
DETENTION FACILITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. OF
TECHNOLOGY GO.
DEVELOPMENT AND THE INTERNET
ASK ACCESS
EXCUSE ME ALLOW PEOPLE TO OBTAIN
SOME INFORMATION THAT HELPS THEM
GROW AND LEARN.
IT HAS HELPED THEM TO STAY
CONNECTED WITH THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS AND CONNECT
THEM WITH SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
THAT ENHANCE THEIR WELL BEING
THE UNITED NATIONS.
HAS. HAS GONE ARMS SO PART TO
DECLARE THAT THE INTERNET ACCESS
IS A HUMAN RIGHT. PEOPLE WHO
CONNECT WHO CANNOT CONNECTED IT.
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY OF THE
INTERNET AVE SERIOUSLY
DISADVANTAGE AS A RESULT OF THAT
FOR EXAMPLE FOSTER YOUTH ARE
MADE OUT OF HOME PLACEMENT AND
JUVENILES AND LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITIES MAY BE CUT OFF. FROM
THE INTERNET ACCESS FOR YEARS AT
A TIME ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES AND COGNITIVE ATTY.
PORTS SYSTEMS IS A BASIC RIGHT
ONTO WHICH THEY ARE OFTEN
DENIED.
LAST YEAR THIS COMMITTEE PASSED
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT ELEVEN WHICH
WAS EXPERT WHICH EXPANDED.
EXPANDED VERSION OF THIS BEALL
HOWEVER.
IT WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR.
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
SHOULD.
COME BACK AND ONLY FOCUS ON THE
LOCAL.
JUVENILE FACILITIES HERE WITH
ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES OF FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT IS LUCY
A CARTER WITH THE.
YOUTH LAW CENTER. AND BLADE O.
STRICT CHO STRAIGHT OSTER RIVER
HERE I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION WHO
WILL PROVIDE TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION UP
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER IS IN THE
SECOND BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
OKAY HELLO I'M I'M LUCY SALZEDO
CARTER WITH THE YOUTH LAW CENTER
AND THE YOUTH LAW CENTER
ADVOCATES TO TRANSFORM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM SO THAT ALL
CHILDREN CAN THRIVE.
WE'RE SPONSORING A AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT.
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE.
IN THE SYSTEMS FACE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES.
AND WE WANT TO HELP ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE SET UP FOR SUCCESS
ACCESS TO COMPUTERS AND THE
INTERNET AS PART OF ENSURING
SUCCESS.
WITHOUT THE FACT THAT IF THEY
REMAIN ISOLATED SOCIALLY THEY
CAN'T DEVELOP VALUABLE CAREER
SKILLS.
AND THEY MISS IMPORTANT
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
COMPUTERS AND THE INTERNET ARE
PART OF NORMAL LIFE
IN TODAY'S SOCIETY. AND WE HAVE
LAWS IN PLACE THAT SUPPORT YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE SYSTEMS
HAVING NORMALCY GETTING TO HAVE
AS NORMAL A LIFE AS THEY CAN
POSSIBLY HAVE.
I'M AND YET MANY OF THEM DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO COMPUTERS AND
TECHNOLOGY.
REMEDY THIS PROBLEM BY ADDING
COMPUTER AND INTERNET.
ACCESS TO THE CODE SECTION THAT
SUPPORTS OTHER NORMAL AGE
APPROPRIATE ACTIVITIES FOR
SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT HELPS
MIXER THAT ACCESS TO COMPUTERS
AND THE INTERNET. IS NOT
DEPENDENT ON THE LUCK OF THE
DRAW WHERE YOU JUST HAPPEN TO BE
PLACED.
BUT IS ACTUALLY.
.
SOMETHING THAT IS CONSISTENT
ACROSS PLACEMENTS.
THE LAW DOES
STILL LEAVE IT UP TO THE CARE
GIVERS TO DECIDE WHAT
CONSTITUTES APPROPRIATE ACCESS.
AND WE KNOW THAT COMPUTER AND
INTERNET ACCESS CAN MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE DIFFERENCE
IN THE LIVES OF SYSTEM INVOLVED
YOUTH WE HAVE A STUDY IN WHICH
I'M FOSTER YOUTH WERE GIVEN
LAPTOPS AND AFTER A YEAR. THEY
REPORTED IMPROVEMENTS IN THEIR
GRADES
BETTER FAMILY CONNECTIONS
IMPROVE RELATIONSHIPS
PIERCE AND FELT BETTER ABOUT
THEIR OWN LIVES.
I'M LAST YEAR WE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT
THE WTA CD ASSASSIN PROBATION TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS I'M
IN THAT PARTICULAR BILL.
.
THIS BILL THIS YEAR TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT REFLECTS
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAME OUT OF
THOSE PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THEIR BLADE OF A
STRIKE I'M TWENTY FIVE YEARS
YOUNGER FORMER JUVENILE
PROBATION AND FOSTERING KINSHIP
YOU.
I AM ALSO A RECENT GRADUATE WITH
MY CRIMINAL JUSTICE DEGREE AND
CURRENTLY WORK AT C. RIGHT C. IS
THE POLICY ADMINISTRATIVE
COORDINATOR.
I REMEMBER LIKE IT WAS YESTERDAY
BEING LOCKED IN THE FACILITY AND
BEING CLOSED OFF FROM THE
OUTSIDE WORLD. COMMUNICATION
WITH THE LUXURY. THE MAN THAT
MANY OF US CAN AFFORD.
TO HAVE COMMUNICATION ON ANY
PLATFORM WAS NOT A NORMALITY
WHETHER.
WHETHER IT IS COOLER FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS AFTER A COUPLE OF
MONTHS OF BEING DETAINED MY
BIGGEST FEAR WAS REINTEGRATION
AND AND HELP THE REHABILITATION
INTO SOCIETY.
THIS IS THE FEAR BECAUSE THERE
WAS LITTLE TO NO RESOURCES THAT
HELPED THIS UNLESS IT WAS A
PROBATION OFFICER. WHOSE MAIN
FOCUS WAS NOT TO MAKE A
PRODUCTIVE HUMAN.
HUMAN BEING BUT TO CREATE THAT
SEX IMBALANCES OF WHAT I NEED TO
COMPLETE WHEN I GET OUT.
WHEN ON THE OUTSIDE OF BEING IN
THE TENTS AND IT WAS HARD FOR ME
TO FIND A JOB.
GET RIGHT BACK INTO SCHOOL
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
COMMUNICATION A HUGE HELP WOULD
BE TO START COMMUNICATING AND
SETTING UP A GAME PLAN WHEN
INSIDE. BEFORE ACCESS. THE
PERFECT PLATFORM FOR THIS GAME
PLAN TO BE CREATED. WOULD BE TO
HAVE INTERNET ACCESS
THIS BILL WOULD NOT ONLY HELP
WITH THEIR REINTEGRATION PROCESS
BUT ALSO FOSTER CREATE IN
PRACTICE HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
WITH FAMILY MENTORS AND FRIENDS.
BEING THAT IT IS TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND ALL SCHOOLS ARE
IT'S SLOWLY INTEGRATING MOST
ACTIVITIES AND LEARNING
MATERIALS TO ELECTRONIC
PLATFORMS INCLUDING INTERNET
ACCESS SOME CORE DOES. IT WOULD
BE A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TO KEEP BY JUVENILE YOUTH AND
FOSTERS UP TO PAR. WITH WITH THE
LEARNING REVOLUTION THAT IS UPON
US.
WITH THE INTERNET ACCESS I WOULD
HAVE BEEN WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN MORE
ACTIVITIES AND CLASSES AND ALSO
SET UP JOBS AND APPLY FOR
MENTORS SIPS. WHILE
INCARCERATED.
AB TWO FOUR FOUR EIGHT WILL
ALLOW FIVE STEVE CLICK MYSELF TO
HAVE A BETTER REINTEGRATION INTO
SOCIETY BY GIVING THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES DEFYING TO MAINTAIN
HEALTHY EDUCATION AND
OPPORTUNITIES. AND KEEP FAMILY
AND FRIENDSHIPS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
URGE YOU AYE VOTE ON AB TWO FOUR
FOUR EIGHT TWO AND SAY THAT ALL
FOSTER CARE.
THE ALL YOU CAN FOSTER CARE IN
YOUTH AND LOCAL. JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITIES HAVE ACCESS
TO COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY AND
INTERNET.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL KENDO
KEYSER ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ANGELIQUE WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS A
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
K. HEARING NONE OF BRING IT UP
TO THE DICE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
WHO?
DR PRICE SUMMARYIT.
FIRST LATE THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDED THE TESTIMONY HIM IS
ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO HEAR THE
TESTIMONY FROM THOSE WHO WOULD
BE MOST AFFECTED. BY LEGISLATION
THAT IS INTRODUCED IN THAT WILL
EVENTUALLY BE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
I I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION.
AL'S WITHIN THE INTERNET ACCESS.
WE ALSO WANT TO PROVIDE AGE
APPROPRIATE AND INTERNET ACCESS
WHAT AGO WHAT.
HOW IS THIS ADDRESSED IN THE
BILL?
THIS ADDRESSED IN THE BILL I'M
THE.
THE FACILITY ITSELF WILL
MONITOR AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS.
AGE APPROPRIATE ACCESS TO.
CERTAIN AREAS.
GUARDS OF THE PLACE UP TO
MAKING SURE THAT AND YOU ARE NOT
IN FACT WANT COMMUNICATING WITH
PEOPLE THEY SHALL NOT
COMMUNICATE WITH THE OUTSIDE
WORLD. AND THEN CERTAINLY THINGS
THAT ARE INAPPROPRIATE SUCH A
SEXUAL IN NATURE.
THOSE KINDS OF SITES WILL BE
STRICKEN FROM THE YOUTH ACCESS.
SO THERE'S BELLS AND WHISTLES
THAT CONNECTS TO THE
AS WELL.
IT'S A VERY GOOD BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I STARTED CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
NUMBER THAT I MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
BILLS THAT MIGHT GET YOU JUMP
BILL ABOUT FIVE ZERO MOVES ON TO
PUBLIC SAFETY THANK THANK YOU
MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALL WALDRON.
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMAN
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT A BEAT THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX.
THE MEASURE THAT CHANGES THE
CALIFORNIA LAW TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL BUREAU OF INDIAN AFFAIRS
TWENTY SIXTEEN INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT REGULATIONS. ALSO
KNOWN AS ECWA. WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND WHILE
GREAT PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN
PROTECTING NATIVE AMERICAN
CHILDREN FROM WHOLESALE
SEPARATION. FROM FROM THEIR
FAMILIES MORE WORK NEEDED TO BE
DONE AND AS A RESULT THE BUREAU
OF INDIAN AFFAIRS REGULATIONS.
ARE CREATED REGULATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL INDIAN CHILDREN
ARE RECEIVING THE SAME
PROTECTIONS ACROSS THE NATION.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY SIX SIMPLY
SEEKS TO CHANGE CALIFORNIA LAW
TO COMPILE WITH FEDERAL LAW.
AND.
WITH ME I HAVE SOME WITNESSES
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE DELIA
SHARP WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL FAMILIES COALITION. AS
WELL AS MAUREEN GEARY WHO IS
FORMER SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH CALIFORNIA INDIAN LEGAL
SERVICES AND OTHER CHAIRMAN AND
TRIBAL MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS MAUREEN
GEARY I'M AN ATTORNEY AND
PARTNER WITH MARISSA FOR KIM
GARRY AND COLIN.
MY LAW FIRM REPRESENTS THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL FAMILIES
COALITION THE SPONSOR PRIOR TO
ENTERING PRIVATE PRACTICE ABOUT
A DECADE AGO I WAS A SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH CALIFORNIA
INDIAN LEGAL SERVICES AND WORKED
THERE FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS. I WAS
THE CHAIR OF THE CI LESS IT WILL
PROJECT AND I REPRESENTED THE
POLYP AND OF MISSION INDIANS ON
THE PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT. UP CALICO.
THE AIM OF CALICO WAS TO
HARMONIZE FEDERAL LEGISLATION
INTENSE WITH STATE LAW.
DESPITE A.
THE.
EQUIFAX ROLE MANDATE AND DESPITE
THE PASSAGE OF CALICO IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS AND
COMPLAINTS ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA.
.
THE BUREAU OF INDIAN AFFAIRS
ECHO REGULATIONS WHICH BECAME
EFFECTIVE DECEMBER OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
IS AN IS AN AGGRESSIVE.
AMENDMENT TO.
ATTEMPT TO TO COMPLY.
I'M SORRY ATTEMPT TO STRENGTHEN
COMPLIANCE WITHIN ECWA.
.
THIS LEGISLATION CAL IT BUT AND
THE.
AMENDMENTS TO CAL ECWA.
THIS LEGISLATION IS NEEDED IN
ORDER TO STRENGTHEN COMPLAINTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND I URGE THE AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU KNOW MY NAME IS
CELIA SHARP I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
FAMILIES COALITION THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL. I'M CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL FAMILIES COALITION IS A
SUCCESSOR ORGANIZATION TO OTHER
CALIFORNIA EQUIP COMPLIANCE TASK
FORCE WHICH WAS CREATED AT THE
INVITATION OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
TO EXAMINE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT
STATEWIDE.
I'M.
THE COALITION IS ACTUALLY
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION WE HAVE
TWENTY FIVE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND AS
OUR MEMBERS AND OUR MISSION IS
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH SAFETY AND
WELFARE. A TRIBAL CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AND CHIVES I'M
SPECIFICALLY THROUGH INCREASING
COMPLIANCE WITH THE INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT.
I'M CONFORMING STATE LAW TO THE
TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN BUREAU
OF INDIAN AFFAIRS ECWA
REGULATIONS IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO ENSURE AND
THE COMPLIANCE IS REALLY
POSSIBLE.
.
IN ORDER TO HAVE CLEAR GUIDANCE
FOR COUNTY.
CHILD WELFARE STAFF IN STATE
COURT JUDGES WE HAVE TO UPDATE
CAL ECHO AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
AB THREE ONE SEVEN SIX DOES I'M
IS IT'S A CONFORMANCE SPELL THAT
UPDATES CAL TECH WHY. I'M AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO A FUTURE
STAKEHOLDER MEETING.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
BILL HAS BEEN CRAFTED TO PROVIDE
THE HIGHEST LEVEL PROTECTIONS
INDIAN CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
TRIBES IN LINE WITH COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND I JUST WANNA THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MONEY HIM MY NAME'S MARYANN
MCGOVERN ON TRIBAL COUNCIL
TREASURER FOR NORTH FORK
RANCHERIA OF MONO INDIANS OF
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO SERVE AS THE
VICE CHAIR FOR THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL FAMILIES COALITION. AND I
AM ONE OF THE.
FOUNDING CO SPONSORS OF THAT
EQUIPPED REPORT THAT WAS
DOUBTLESS
WE OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT AB THREE
ONE SEVEN SIX AND WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A HIGHWAYMAN
CHECKETTS* I'M CHAIRMAN A
WILL RANCHERIA ME WHAT TRIBE
WHERE THE ONLY FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO CAN.
WITH THAT BEING SAID DIFFERENT
COUNTIES LOOK AT EQUITY ISSUES
VERY DIFFERENTLY AND ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE IS THE
EDUCATION OF THE JUDGES THAT
COUNTY COUNCIL.
THE INVESTIGATORS AND ALSO THE
SOCIAL WORKERS TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND IT WORK
COMPLIANCE FOR TINA FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND AND OUR
RIGHTS TO PROTECT OUR INDIAN
CHILDREN. SO THIS BILL HELPS TO
SOLIDIFY FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES TO
HAVE A STANDARD THAT'S THAT'S
NEAR TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND THAT WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL
FOR FOR US ESPECIALLY IN THIS
COUNTY TO HELP EDUCATE THEM AND
HAVE A CONSISTENCY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SO.
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY SIX
SPONSORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WANT OKAY ANY
OTHERS IN OUR SUPPORT. PUBLIC
TREAT ON BEHALF OF THE CHIANG
INCLUSIVE TRIBES OF FIRST I'D
LIKE TO HANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WRASSE FOR HER IT WILL BUILD A
DATE IT'S ON CONSENT. THANK
ASSEMBLY WOMAN OF COLOR AYE
WALDRON ON HER PALE ANY OF THESE
BILLS ON EQUITY OUT BROUGHT BY
THIS GROUP. WILL REALLY HELP THE
SAFETY OF INDIAN CHILDREN AND I
ENCOURAGE AS MANY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TO COME ONCE CO AUTHORS.
IF YOU.
CHRIS LUNCH FROM CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL BUSINESS ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT IS CONFORMITY BILL AND
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THIS IS
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY. OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL FAMILIES
COALITION.
MADAM CHAIR SCOTT GOVERNOR BAFTA
MORONGO BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN POWER WITH THE LANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS SUPPORT.
AND GIVE.
ANGELIQUE WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI ROXANNE BACK MOMMY ON HAVE ON
BEHALF OF HAVE A MULLET. PROMO
VEPR LAKE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BUT THAT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF
I COULD BE A QUORUM DURING YOUR
BILL.
QUE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
DAIS.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
I WANTED TO THANK SOMEONE ARE
WALDRON FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND SIMILARLY ASK IF I
CAN TALK TO YOUR BILL AND.
POTENTIALLY THE ONE ACROSS THE
WAY AS WELL SO THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MIND. I I WOULD
GET A HER DUPLICATE THAT
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUE THINKS.
AS A MEMBER WATER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO BE ADDED IS CAUGHT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
ON MY BEHALF OF MY EQUIPPED ILL
PEOPLE FEEL THREE CAN BE CO
AUTHOR SENATOR.
AND I AM ALREADY A CO AUTHOR
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENT.
OKAY WITH THAT WHICH IS LIKE
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE.
YOU'RE DENY VOTE ON THE SUPPORT
BILL THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AND THE BILL GO IT'S A
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS IS A SUCH
A. TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AND I'M GONNA.
BUT I'M GLAD I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I'VE BRANCHED.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
BILLS GETS.
OKAY THE BILL'S OUT SIX TO SARAH
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIGHT YES
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS LOCATED IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS BY THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFFOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE. ON THIS BILL.
AB TWO SEVEN FOUR FOUR PROVIDES
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AROUND THE
ACTIVITIES OF REFERRAL AGENCIES
FOR FAMILIES LOOKING TO PLACE
THE DISABLED.
AND SENIOR FAMILY MEMBERS INTO
LONG TERM RESIDENTIAL CARE.
ASSURING THAT CONSUMERS HAVE
CLEAR TRANSPARENT INFORMATION
ABOUT THE REFERRAL PROCESS AND
THOSE MINIMUM STANDARDS
ARE MET.
FINDING QUALITY HOUSING AND CARE
FOR A LOVED ONE IS DAUNTING EVEN
UNDER THE MOST IDEAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
FOR MOST THIS DECISION CAN FEEL
RUSHED CREATING AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT MAKES FAMILIES MORE
VULNERABLE.
TO THE PRESSURE AND
MISINFORMATION THE MIGHT BE
PROVIDED TO THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY CONSUMERS OFTEN DO
NOT HAVE THE TIME RESOURCES OR
EXPORT EXPERTISE TO MAKE THE
MOST INFORMED DECISIONS FOR
THEMSELVES. OR THEIR LOVED ONES
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
ELDER CARE PLACEMENT AND HOUSING
OPTIONS.
IT IS AT THIS JUNCTURE THE
REFERRAL AGENCY CAN BE OF GREAT
HELP.
OR GREAT HARM.
TO CALIFORNIANS
REFERRAL AGENCIES OFFER SENIORS
AND FAMILIES.
ASSISTANCE
FINDING PLACEMENT IN A CARE
FACILITY USUALLY A LICENSED
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY FOR
THE ELDERLY.
THESE ARE OFTEN FREE OF CHARGE
TO THE PERSON BEING REFERRED.
THESE REFERRAL AGENCIES ARE
LARGELY UNREGULATED IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES THEY RECEIVE ARE NOT
ALWAYS THE CLEARLY DISCLOSE TO
THE SENIOR. BEING PLACED OR
THEIR FAMILIES.
REFERRAL AGENCIES ALSO ARE NOT
ALWAYS NECESSARILY FAMILIAR WITH
THE FACILITIES TO WHICH THEY'RE
REFERRING SENIORS. OR EVEN THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THE SENIORS
THEY ARE REFERRING.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THESE THAT
THESE ISSUES AND PROVIDES A NEED
TO TRANSPARENCY AND PROTECTION
NEEDED.
HERE TO TESTIFY BEHALF OF THE
BILL.
ARE LINDA ARE MOST DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL REFERRAL
EMPLACEMENT ALLIANCE.
RONALD SIMPSON DIRECTOR AT ANTS
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PRESIDENT OF SIX BEDS INK.
AND WITH US ALSO IS ROXANA GOULD
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS WHO WILL
ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE.
WHEN AN ELDERLY PERSON MAKES
WHAT'S OFTEN THE LAST TO MOVE OF
THEIR LIFE IT'S RARELY A JOYOUS
OCCASION. A LOT OF A MOTIONS OF
CONFUSION STRESSES INVOLVED
PREVIOUSLY THIS PROFESSION HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY UNREGULATED. AND
AND NO CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
MANY PEOPLE ARE NOT EVEN AWARE
OF THE VALUABLE SERVICE THAT
SENIOR REFERRAL AGENCIES PROVIDE
UNTIL THEY'RE IN THE MIDST OF A
CRISIS AND AND. OFTEN ONLY HAVE
FORTY EIGHT HOURS TOFIND A
PLACE FOR A LOVED ONE WHO'S
WHO'S BEING DISCHARGED FROM A
HOSPITAL. UNABLE TO GO HOME.
THEN THERE'S NO TIME TO SHOP
AROUND. THE PUBLIC MAKES
REASONABLE ASSUMPTIONS WHEN THEY
ARE ME. READ PROMISES ABOUT
EXPERT ADVISORS.
THAT WILL HOLD THEIR HANDS
THROUGH EVERY STEP OF THE
PROCESS TO HELP THEM FIND PLACES
TAILORED TO THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS.
THEY DON'T THINK TO QUESTION
WHETHER THAT SENIOR HOUSING
ADVISER EXPERT. HAS EVER SEEN OR
KNOWS ANYTHING ABOUT THE PLACES
THEY ARE RECOMMENDING. IT
SHOULDN'T MATTER WHETHER A
FAMILIES SEARCHING ONLINE OR
USING A LOCAL REFERRAL AGENCY
THE SAME STANDARD SHOULD APPLY.
TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE DO
MATTER. THERE'S A CONDITION
CALLED RELOCATION STRESS
SYNDROME OR TRANSFER TRAUMA.
THAT CAN CAUSE CRITICAL
EMOTIONAL AND BEHAVIORAL
SYMPTOMS ESPECIALLY IN FRAIL ARE
CONFUSED ELDERLY.
SEARCHING FOR APPROPRIATE
HOUSING AND CARE IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN SHOPPING FOR A
PAIR OF SHOES ARE AN OUTFIT.
THAT CAN BE RETURNED IF IT'S NOT
A GOOD FIT.
A PLACE PERFECT FOR ONE PERSON
MAY BE COMPLETELY WRONG OR EVEN
DANGEROUS FOR ANOTHER.
FAMILIES SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
HONEST DISCLOSURE THAT THE
AGENCY WILL BE PAID A
COMMISSION.
AND THE RIGHT TO CANCEL IF NOT
SATISFIED WITH THE SERVICES OF
AN AGENCY.
THERE ARE A MULTITUDE OF
INNOCUOUS LOOKING WEBSITES
POSING AS INFORMATIONAL SITES.
THAT MEAN WE SERVE TO CAPTURE
CONTACT INFORMATION TO BE SOLD.
AND USED FOR REFERRALS TO
ASSISTED LIVING COMMUNITIES FOR
A COMMISSION OFTEN THE FAMILY
HAS NO KNOWLEDGE THIS HAS
HAPPENED UNTIL THEIR PHONE
STARTS RINGING. THE COMPANY CAN
ALSO CLAIM TO REPRESENT THE
CLIENT INDEFINITELY WITHOUT
THEIR PERMISSION.
EVEN AFTER BEING TOLD TO CEASE
CONTACT AND MAY STILL COLLECT
COMMISSIONS YEARS LATER BECAUSE
OF TERMS BURIED IN THE PRIVACY
POLICY FINE PRINT.
BECAUSE THEY NEVER ACTUALLY
OPTED IN THERE IS NO WAY TO OPT
OUT.
FAMILIES DESERVE CHOICES AND
TRANSPARENCY FOR THESE REASONS
WE.
WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
SMELL.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND ROCK
SINGLE REPRESENTING SIXPENCE
INCUMBENT HERE TO TESTIFY I'M.
HERE TO NOT INTRODUCE RON
SIMPSON WHO IS ON THE BOARD AT
SIX BEDS WHICH IS AN ASSOCIATION
OF SMALL RESIDENTS RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY
SIX BEDS OR FEWER. A SMALL
FAMILY TYPESETTING AND SO OUT
WITHOUT HIM DOCTOR ON A FEW.
THANKS MIKE SENT.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY FOUR IS ABOUT.
PROTECTING SENIORS AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE COMPLICATED
PROCESS OF FINDING AN
APPROPRIATE CARE FACILITY.
FAMILIES IN NEED IN THIS
SITUATION ARE USUALLY IN CRISIS.
IT IS ALSO A DIFFICULT EMOTIONAL
TIME.
OVER FIFTY PERCENT OF THOSE
SEEKING
HELP FEEL GUILTY ABOUT MAKING
THIS PLACEMENT.
CONSEQUENTLY THEY ARE E.. EVEN
MORE VULNERABLE AND OFTEN
UNAWARE THAT AS THEY GO INTO THE
INTERNET SEEKING INFORMATION
THEY'RE AGREEING TO ALLOW A
REFERRAL AGENCY. NOT ONLY TO
DISCLOSE BUT EVEN TO SELL THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
MUCH MORE TRANSPARENCY IS NEEDED
IN THIS AREA AND THIS BILL WILL
CODIFY THAT REQUIREMENT.
JUST LAST WEEK I MET WITH THE
GENTLEMAN LOOKING FOR
REPLACEMENT FOR HIS MOTHER.
HE TOLD ME JUST DAYS BEFORE HE
WENT ON THE INTERNET SEEKING
INFORMATION ANY OTHER HARDLY
FINISHED.
WHEN HIS PHONE STARTED RINGING
NONSTOP.
PEOPLE SEEKING HELP FOR REFERRAL
AGENCIES EXPECT INDIVIDUALS
REPRESENTING THEMSELVES AS
EXPERTS TO UNDERSTAND BASIC CARE
REQUIREMENTS FOR SUCH THINGS AS
COGNITIVE LOSS DIABETES
CONGESTIVE HEART FAILURE.
AND. CURRENTLY THERE IS NO
TRAINING REQUIREMENT ANYONE.
ANYONE CAN SAY THAT THEY ARE AN
EXPERT REFERRAL AGENT.
WE NEED TO CHANGE THAT AND
ESTABLISH A MINIMAL TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS SO FAMILIES ARE
REASSURED THAT REFERRAL AGENTS
CAN EVALUATE. AND MAKE
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENTS.
THERE IS GRAPHED IN COLLUSION IN
THIS INDUSTRY THAT INFLUENCES
THE WAY CLIENTS ARE REQUIRED AND
REFERRALS ARE MADE.
THIS RESULTS IN REFERRALS MADE
FREQUENTLY FOR FINANCIAL GAIN
NOT FOR THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
NEEDY SENIORS.
THE IS PERVASIVE INDUSTRY
KICKBACKS CONTINUE EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE UNETHICAL IF NOT
ILLEGAL.
THIS CREATES UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES AND EVEN WORSE AN
INCENTIVE FOR PLACEMENTS AND
FACILITIES THAT ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE.
THIS BILL OPENS TO PRACTICAL
SIGNIFICANT MEANS OF ENFORCEMENT
ONE.
AND ACTION IN SMALL CLAIMS COURT
INTO REMOVAL FROM THIS REGISTRY
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES MAKING IT ILLEGAL TO
PROVIDE A REFERRAL.
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON.
AB TWO TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FOURTH
TO CREATE IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS
FOR THE SENIOR ADULTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS HEATHER HARRISON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION WE'RE PROUD TO BE A
CO SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN THE MORRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD WERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LILIA
MOTI SEAL AYE MY SIX BED
FACILITY OPERATOR IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI KIMBERLY GEIS A SIX BED OWNER
OPERATOR ADMINISTRATOR AND STE
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HELLO.
GLEN BERRY.
IN.
RESIDENTIAL CARE EXPERIENCE FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS HEARING
CALIFORNIAN EXPERIENCE WITH
PLACEMENT AGENCIES AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI CINDY MINARET OPERATOR OF
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
SENTIMENT SUPPORT.
I'M I'M ED BORROW SHE'LL.
IT'S BAD INCORPORATE THE.
I IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ELLEN ABELL HAS A DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTS.
THANK YOU.
I'M GINA Y. SPIKE ON A CARE HOME
OPERATOR AMONG ALSO AND MEMBER
OF SIX BITS. I'M IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I MINUS ODDBALL ARM ON SIX BIT
OPERATOR AND A MEMBER OF SIX
BEDS INK I MEAN IT'S A POINT.
THANK YOU.
JERRY SEMI CELEBRATE OR EVEN ON
ORANGE COUNTY IN FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THESE ARE COMMON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AND.
IT JUST IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
UNTIL WE HAVE A DIALOGUE THAT
ALLOWS FOR PLANNING FOR LONG
TERM CARE FOR OUR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ARE FAMILIES ARE GOING
TO TURN TO THESE REFERRAL
AGENCIES IN CRISIS TELL PLEASE
OUT. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER ON BEHALF OF ALZHEIMER'S
ORANGE COUNTY AND ALZHEIMER'S
GREATER LOS ANGELES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I MILLIONS HIS TIE AND.
OUR OWN THE FIVE CARE HOMES FOR
ELDERLY AND NAM A MEMBER ALSO OF
SIXPENCE.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT ANY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ISOGON
HIS IDEA.
OUR STATE EPPIE OWNER IN
SACRAMENTO.
MEMBER OF SIX BED I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI AM GRACEFULLY I'M OF THE
HOUSE IS THE LIVING OWNERS AND
I'M STRONG SUPPORT BURDENS THANK
YOU.
I AM TEST JOHN WELCOME A CARE
HOME OPERATOR. IN SAN FRANCISCO
OF HOME. AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S SOLIDITY AND THE
OUR CFE OPERATOR FROM SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
KATE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CLIFF
BURKE HERE BEHALF OF PLACE FOR
MOM OF THE COUNTRY'S LEADING.
.
NATIONAL REFERRAL AGENCY ON THE
INTERNET.
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND ARE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR TO HOPEFULLY GET
THERE. ARE WITH THE SPONSORS.
.
YOU JUST BY WAY OF BRIEF HISTORY
A PLACE FOR MOM SUPPORTED
SIMILAR LEGISLATION OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS AUTHORED BY
SENATOR MENDOZA VETO BY THE
GOVERNOR. ON WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH TRANSPARENCY
NOTICE AND.
PROVIDING CONSUMERS WITH
PROTECTION AYE WHEN WE FIRST SAW
THIS BILL WE WERE CONCERNED THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PROVISIONS
THAT DIDN'T SEEM TO GO TO
PROTECTING THE ELDERLY. OR
CONSUMERS BUT SEEM TO GO TO
TILTING THE PLAYING FIELD IN THE
ECONOMIC RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS.
I WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND HER STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH ITS
MOST OF THOSE PROVISIONS ALL
CAME OUT. WELL WITH THE
AMENDMENT SO ARM WE ACTUALLY
HAVE ONE MAJOR ISSUE LEFT WITH
THE BILL ARM WHICH I WILL
MENTION HOPEFULLY WE CONTINUE TO
WORK OUT. THAT'S LANGUAGE THAT
IS IN THE BILL THAT IN ESSENCE
WE THINK INSERTS
THE CONSUMER IN THE FAMILY INTO
OF. POTENTIAL FEE DISPUTE
BETWEEN MULTIPLE REFERRAL
AGENCIES
SO THE STANDARD INDUSTRY
PRACTICE IN THE STANDARD
CONTRACT IN THIS BUSINESS.
REMEMBER IN THIS SITUATION THE
CONSUMERS ARE PAYING A FEE AT
ALL IN ESSENCE THE REFERRAL FEES
PAID BY THE FACILITY TO THE
REFERRAL AGENCY.
A STANDARD CONTRACT IN THE
INDUSTRY IN THE BUSINESS MODEL
ABSENCES THOSE CONTRACTS ALL SAY
FIRST IN TIME WITH THE REFERRAL
GETS PAID. WELL WHILE IT MAY BE
SOMEWHAT ARBITRARY IN IN IN
ANYONE'S MIND IT. ITSELF WHICH
IS A SYSTEM THAT HAS WORKED WELL
IN THE INDUSTRY OVERALL. ON THIS
BILL CONTAINS A PROVISION THAT
IN ESSENCE CONTRAVENES THOSE
CONTRACTS IN SAYS THE FACILITY
MAY GO TO THE CONSUMER. ASKS THE
CONSUMER WHO THEY THINK THEY
LIKE THE BEST
AND THEN THE FACILITY CAN RELY
UPON THAT TO PAY THAT REFERRAL
AGENCY OVER. THE OTHER REFERRAL
AGENCY IN MANY OF THE SITUATIONS
THAT WE SEE ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS THE FAMILY ITSELF IS
DIVIDED. AND THE FAMILY MAY HAVE
MULTIPLE SIBLINGS WHO TRIED TO
DO THE BEST FOR THEIR PARENTS
HAVE CALLED DIFFERENT REFERRAL
AGENCIES.
INVOLVE MULTIPLE REFERRAL
AGENCIES
WE DON'T THINK IN THIS HIGHLY
STRESSFUL SITUATION WHERE WE ARE
INDEED IN A LIFE MILESTONES
SITUATION.
APPROPRIATE TO PUT THE CONSUMER
FAMILY IN A PER SITUATION WHERE
REFERRAL AGENCIES WILL BE
PRESSURING THEM TO SAY PICK ME
PICK ME TO GET THE FREE. ARM SO
WE BELIEVE THAT ONE PROVISION
REALLY IS NOT IN THE CONSUMER'S
BEST INTERESTS OTHER THAN THAT.
OF ANY OTHER SUGGESTIONS WE HAVE
A FAIRLY CLARIFYING AND MINOR ON
WE'RE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
DISCLOSURE NOTICE FOR CONSUMERS
TRAINING AND PER CAN SIMMER
PROTECTION. WILL WE DO WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
PROVISION IN THERE FOR AT THIS
POINT WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE. ARM
IN A POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
BILL ON HAVE TO OPPOSE IT TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEN NONE OF QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
OF THE UP TO CHOI.
I THINK THIS IS ANOTHER.
CRITICAL ISSUE.
OH IN THE YOU REFERRAL.
.
IF YOU REGISTER.
AS HELLER COPIES TO PAYER.
I'M A WAY FOR SERVICE PERSON.
WHAT HOW WOULD YOU?
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF THEM
REFERRING PERSON THE PERSON HAS
TO HAVE SOME KNOWLEDGE OF ALL.
THE FACILITY IS A PERSON IS
GONNA.
NOT RECOMMEND OR HAVE VISITED
THE WAR.
WHAT WOULD BE WHAT WOULD MAKE IT
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN?
PRIOR.
THE CONDITION AND THAT AFTER
THIS SO ENACTED TO BAIL.
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO ONE OF
OUR.
.
ONE OF OUR SPEAKERS.
HOWEVER.
AS WITH ANYTHING I THINK THAT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE A REFERRAL
TO A PARTICULAR.
PLACE.
THE IT SHOULD BE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE PERSON YOU'RE REFERRING
AS OPPOSED TO FINANCIAL GAIN FOR
THE ONE MAKING THE REFERRAL. THE
I THAT I SIGNED A STANDOUT PART
THOUGH IT IN WITHOUT PUTTING
REFERRING PER SON.
EVEN THE TO EQUAL ONE.
OF THEY MADE OUT RECOMMEND
AGENCY AYE EIGHTY IF AGENTS A
PAGE BEAM MORE.
BUT.
THIS A REQUIREMENT A TO REGISTER
WITH A SOCIAL SERVICES.
HOW WOULD YOU DO IT IMPROVE MY
SERVICE QUALITY?
JUST ARE.
JUST A PAPER WORKER TO FIVE
HAVE.
HOW WOULD THE DEPARTMENT THE
ASSURE THAT THE AFTER I HAVE
BEEN REGISTERED THE MY CBS?
QUALITY WOULD BE BETTER THAN.
IN ALL.
NO SUCH REGULATION.
A GOOD QUESTION I'M GOING TO ASK
MS COOLED IF SHE WILL SURE
ABSOLUTELY THAT ARGUES MONTHS
NOTHING GOLD REPRESENTING SIX
BEDS.
I'M OUR OBJECTIVE WITH THE BILL
IS TO.
TO PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY CLARITY
WHAT WE GET WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS THAT I HAD A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WERE OF LOOKING FOR A
PLACE FOR MY MOM. AYE BECAUSE OF
THE BENEFIT OF REPRESENTING SIX
BEDS I KNEW THE NAME OF THE
FACILITY THAT I WANTED TO GO TO.
I WENT ONLINE AND I WENT THROUGH
SIX GOOGLE PAGE SEARCHES WHERE
WAS ONE. ONE LISTING AFTER
ANOTHER WITH A PICTURE OF A HOME
REPRESENTING AS IF IT WAS THE
HOME I WAS LOOKING FOR I CALLED
AND IT WAS INSTEAD REFERRAL
AGENCY. AND SO OUR CONCERN IS
FIRST OF ALL AND THERE IS NOT AN
INCENTIVE FOR THOSE AGENCIES TO
BE FAMILIAR WITH THE CONDITION
OF THE PERSON THEY'RE PLACING.
THOUGH IT HAD NOT BEEN A
REQUIREMENT FOR THEM HAVE ANY
FAMILIARITY WITH THE FACILITY TO
PLACING THEM IN THE BACK AND ONE
OF THE COMMITTEES.
A REFERRAL AGENCY THATWAS NOT
A PLACE FOR MOM SAID I CAN'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
FACILITIES THAT WORK IN NEW
JERSEY. WE THINK THAT DOESN'T
MATTER WE THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE
TO KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT MY MOM
SOMETHING ABOUT THE PLACE YOU'RE
PLACING HER SO THAT IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE RELATIONSHIP AND
THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT THE FEE
IS TRUE.
YOU KNOW IT IT THEY ARE THEY ARE
ON.
THEY ADVERTISE THAT IT'S FREE.
IT'S TRUE IT'S FREE TO THE
PERSON THEY'RE PLACING BUT IT
THERE FOR A SIX BED FACILITY IF
IT'S A MONTH OR MONTH AND A
HALF.
RENT WE HAVE TO PAY THE REFERRAL
AGENCY WE THINK THAT THE PERSON
BEING PLACED SHOULD KNOW THAT
THERE'S AN INCENTIVE FOR THAT
EIGHT THAT AGENCY TO REFER THEM
TO PARTICULAR HOME BECAUSE OF
THAT FEET. AND SO THEY'RE
STRAINING IN THE BELL.
WHICH WILL HELP TO MAKE SURE
THEY KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT THE
CONDITION AND I BELIEVE THIS
REQUIREMENT FOR THEM TO HAVE A
FAMILIARITY WITH THE FACILITY
THEIR PLACE IN THE RESIDENT
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T
EXIST TODAY.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE SO
SCREENING PROCEDURE IN THIS BILL
THAT THE HARLEM MY SERVICE TO MY
KNOWLEDGE OF TI FACILITIES ARE
I'M ABOUT TO RECOMMEND TO MY
CLIENTS A TRAINING REQUIREMENT
YES.
WHO'S GONNA DO TRAINING.
BUT I THINK IT WAS TRAINER CRIME
EITHER THROUGH DSS OR OUTSIDE
SOURCES WITH DSS WOULD BE THE
REGULATORY AUTHORITY TO ENSURE
THE TRAINING IS ADEQUATE
INAPPROPRIATE.
IT'S A REGISTRATION PROCESS
WHICH IS.
ONE REASON WE BELIEVE THE
GOVERNOR VETOED A PREVIOUS BILL
BECAUSE IT WAS A LICENSING DEL
WHICH ADDED EXTENSIVE COST SO
THAT'S WHY IT'S A REGISTRATION
PROCESS TO TRY TO ALLEVIATE THAT
FINANCIALLY OR INTENT IS GOOD
BUT DOWN TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOUGHT THIS PSALM.
IT EDITION HONOR REGULATION.
TO REGISTER NOW FOR. THE
REFERRING PERSON.
WHO WAS DOING THAT THIRTY FOREST
SERVICE OUT WATER?
BUT NOT ONLY JUST GOING THROUGH
A COMMISSIONER OF OUR
REGULATIONS AND THEY ARE IN
REGISTRATION COSTA WHATEVER.
ACTUALLY.
.
YOU KNOW MY NOT KNOWLEDGE IN THE
MORNING. ARE ETHICS OF WOULD BE
IMPACTS TO BUY THIS BILL SO WHY
NOT JUST OF. PAPERWORK ON
KNOWLEDGE OF BUT THE ACTUAL FOR
EXAMPLE KILL GRAFICA.
A I COME FROM ORANGE COUNTY IF I
TO REFORM SERVICE A IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
THAN THE SOME SOME LIMITATIONS
SO THAT THOUGHT I WOULD HAVE
ABILITY TO VISIT THE OF THE
FACILITIES ARE IN MY AREA I HAVE
A SOME INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
SAID FACILITIES AND STAFF
MEMBERS. AND THEN ALSO CLIENT
CONDITION AND IF TO SELL OR
TIMER OF. A SUFFERING PATIENT
THE THEN THE SUDDEN FACILITY
WOULD HAVE A BETTER.
KIDDO A GIVING NAM ABILITY THAN
YOU CAN WE FOR.
MAYBE TWO THIRTY YEAH AND THEN
THE FAMILIES THAT WOULD DECIDE
ON THE AND ULTIMATELY KNOW BY
COMPARISON. NOT JUST OF.
MY YOU KNOW.
YEAH ARMCHAIR PAPERWORK ON AND
THEN YOU CORD VIA FIND OUT THE.
SO WHAT I HOPE FOR THIS BILL
WOULD ACTUALLY.
DEMAND THE.
CORD FOR WITH OUT REFORM
SERVICES SAW A WILL ENHANCE THE
ONCOLOGY AND THEN ETHICS.
WE WOULD WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING WHAT
YOUR OBJECTIVE IS IS EXACTLY THE
OBJECTIVE OF THE BILL SUCH. YOU
KNOW WE AND KNOW WHERE TRYING TO
PASS SOMETHING THAT REALLY JUST
GOING TO BE PUSHING ALL OF THE
PAPER AROUND AND NOT DO ANYTHING
AT THE END OF THE DAY SUCKING
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY I HAVE OWNED UP WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE AND I HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION AS TO PATH AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGING AND LONG TERM
CARE.
WHICH LEX CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ANSWERING AYE VOTE THANK YOU CAN
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
DUTCH CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I'D DAIS A FAIR
SIZED STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND THURMOND AYE.
ISN'T IT
WELL.
IT WILL DO THE ON CALL BILLS
FIRST.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
REGULATIONS PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DOCTOR
CHOI.
ARAMBULA.
I THINK IT'S A. ITEM SIX.
DUTCH CHOI I KNOW.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NOT VOTING BERMAN.
THURMOND AYE VILLAGE UP.
BELLSOUTH FOUR ZERO FOUR WHEN
I'M SORRY FOR ONE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO DIE
RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. DOCTOR CHOI.
NOT CHOI NOT VOTING.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I. THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE VILLAGE OUT.
OKAY THE BELLS OUT FIVE ZERO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY DURING.
ITEM TWENTY THREE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
KALRA.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND I MILITIA REDUNDANT
.
ALRIGHT THAT BRINGS US TO.
OUR CHAIRS BILLS.
THANK YOU.
WHAT SO ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY EIGHT?
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY EIGHT A BILL THAT
COMPLIMENTS MY ASSEMBLY BILL
SOME FIFTY TWO FROM LAST YEAR
WHICH PROHIBITS PRESCHOOL
EXPULSION DUE TO CHILD.
CHILD'S BEHAVIOR AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY EIGHT ENABLES CHILDREN IN
THE CALIFORNIA'S THE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM TO BENEFIT FROM EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT GETTING
RESOURCES INTO THE CLASSROOM TO
HELP ADDRESS CHALLENGING
BEHAVIORS AND PREVENTING FUTURE
EXPULSIONS WERE SIMPLY
AUTHORIZING PROVIDERS TO UTILIZE
EXISTING SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
FUNDING TO PROVIDE THESE
VALUABLE SERVICES WHICH RESEARCH
SHOWS. WILL IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN NATIONALLY THREE OUT OF
FOUR.
I'M SORRY NATIONALLY THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS AND ROLL THEM PRE
K. ARE EXPELLED. THREE IN AT
THREE POINT TWO TIMES MORE
FREQUENTLY THAN K. TWELVE
STUDENTS WHILE CALIFORNIA'S
PRESCHOOL.
PRE K. EXPULSION RATES ARE EVEN
HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
FROM THIS DATA WE CONCLUDE THAT
PRE K. EXPULSION.
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
CHILDREN OF COLOR THESE THIS
BILL WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
PROVIDERS TO PURSUE EFFECTIVE
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION MODELS WHICH WE
KNOW IN ADDITION TO OTHER
BENEFICIAL OUTCOMES. CAN HELP
WITH REDUCING EXPLOSIONS WITH
EXISTING CONTRACT FUNDS I HAVE.
HERE WITH ME ADDRESS GARCIA
WITH TO DANGLE THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL TO TALK MORE ABOUT
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH THIS PLACE.
SHARON MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME AS A PLACE HERE HI
MY NAME'S ON THAT I SEE AND I'M
THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
ORGANIZATIONAL LEADERSHIP
ACCUTANE GO. HIGH OVERSEE BOTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES.
GETTING GO IS A NONPROFIT EARLY
EDUCATION PROVIDER THAT SERVES
NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND CHILDREN.
AND ABOUT NINETY FIVE PERCENT OF
THE FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE
RECEIVE FREE OR LOW COST CARE.
SO MEDICAL CONSULTATION IS
IMPORTANT AND WE NEED TO
INCREASE
THE ACCESS FOR THE ULTIMATE
BENEFIT OF ALL CHILDREN.
SO THIS MODEL PROVIDES CRUCIAL
SUPPORT FOR EFFECTIVE CLASSROOM
MANAGEMENT AND POSITIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS INCLUDING
STRATEGIES TO SUPPORT CHILDREN
WITH CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS AND
OTHER SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
SO THIS TRULY IS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT TO THE COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH BETWEEN THE MENTAL
HEALTH CONSULTANTS THE TEACHERS
THE PARENTS AND OTHER EARLY
EDUCATION PROVIDING STAFF.
TO REALLY PARTNER TOGETHER AND
IMPROVE THE OUTCOMES OF ALL
CHILDREN ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ARE HAVING THE AIR EXHIBITING
THE CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS.
SO I WANT TO SHARE JUST ONE
STORY WITH YOU TAKE THIS IS A
TRANSFORMATIVE OUTCOME OF
CONSULTATION QUE.
JACKSON CAME INTO THE CLASSROOM
WITH THE HISTORY THAT REALLY NO
FOUR YEAR OLD SHOULD NEVER HAVE.
WHICH CONTRIBUTED TO A A
VULNERABLE LEARNING FOUNDATION
FOR HIM.
IN MOMENTS OF DISTRESS
YOU WOULD SEE HIM KICK SCREAM
BITE AND HIT.
ALL OF THESE HAD REALLY BECOME
THE NORM AND NOW HE WAS
FUNCTIONING IN THIS CLASSROOM.
SO. YOU KNOW THERE WAS A CLIMATE
OF STRESS THAT HAD REALLY
STARTED TO TO.
OVERSHADOW THE CLASSROOM AND
THE TEACHERS ALTHOUGH VERY
EXPERIENCED
THEY WERE PHILLY PUSHED TO THE
EDGE AND THEIR ABILITY TO REALLY
PROVIDE SUPPORT. AND THEY WANTED
TO TRULY TAP INTO HIS POTENTIAL
ALTHOUGH CLOUDED HE WAS STILL
VERY CREATIVE HE WAS REALLY
PLAYFUL AND THEY WANTED TO
SUPPORT THAT.
SO THE CONSULTANTS AND
COLLABORATION WITH THE PARENTS
AND THE TEACHERS WERE ABLE TO
JOIN TOGETHER AND IDENTIFIED
THAT WOULD JACKSON'S.
SPECIFIC NEEDS AND THEY
DEVELOPED A JOINT MENTAL HEALTH
ENHANCED.
BE ABLE PLAN FOR HIM SUPPORT
PLAN.
SO THROUGHOUT SOMETIME WITH
COLOR COLLABORATION CAN YOU TENT
CONTINUING AND THE PERSISTENCE
OF THE TEACHER THE CONSULTANTS
AND THE PARENTS.
IT THAT'S THE POINT WHERE
JACKSON WAS MUCH MORE CALM IN
THE CLASSROOM WAS ABLE TO
ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN LEARNING AND
HIS OVERALL HOME.
INTERACTIONS WITH BOTH HIS PEERS
AND HIS TEACHERS WERE MUCH MORE
POSITIVE.
SO THIS REALLY ALLOWED THE
ENTIRE CLASS TO REFOCUS THEIR
THEIR ENERGY INTO THE JOY OF
REALLY LEARNING.
SO PARTS OF CONSULTATION JACKSON
REALLY WAS ON THE PATH TOWARDS
X..
EXPULSION.
MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATION
REALLY TRANSFORMED THAT FORK FOR
JACKSON.
AND THIS IS JUST ONE STORY BUT
THERE ARE MANY MANY OTHER
JACKSON'S OUT THERE. THAT COULD
REALLY BENEFIT FROM A BILL LIKE
THIS
SO I JUST THINK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I APPRECIATE YOU
CONSIDERING AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
EIGHT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THING THAT ANYONE IS IN
OPPOSITION.
SINGER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THREATS.
I JUST LOVE YOUR STORY OF
JACKSON.
BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS EVERY
CHILD SHOULD HAVE THAT.
.
PUTTING A CHILD ON THE PATH TO
EXPULSION AND WE KNOW THAT THEN
IF THAT'S THE BEGINNING OF. OF
THE THE HILL THAT'S THE
BEGINNING OF EVERYTHING GO
WRONG.
SO I APPRECIATE FIRST OF ALL OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU'RE BRINGING
THAT THIS BILL FORWARD. BUT
HONESTLY WE DO NEED TO PROVIDE
THAT SERVICE TO OUR TO OUR
CHILDREN AT ALL AGES.
THANK YOU.
YOU.
HEATHER COVER.
SING NONE.
GOV ESTIMATE.
THANK YOU HAS TWENTY THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE BILL I SPENT.
FOUR YEARS WORKING FOR AN
AGENCY THAT ACTUALLY PROVIDES
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION IN THAT SO MUCH OF
THE STORY AND JACKSON I WOULD IS
ARTICULATE.
WHAT WE HEARD FROM PARENTS AND
HOW MUCH THEY APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT?
AND BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THEIR
THEIR CHILDREN AND ULTIMATELY
SUPPORT THEM HAVING A POSITIVE
OUTCOME SO I THINK THE AUTHOR
THINK THE WITNESS IS SET FOR
THIS BILL.
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
YES THANK YOU ARE IN THE CLUB
I'M AS A MOTHER OF TWO AND AND
AS A FORMER TEACHER I CAN'T TELL
YOU ENOUGH. HOW CRITICAL THE
SERVICES ARE AND I WISH THAT A
WEEK IT CAN CARRY THIS OVER NOT
ONLY TO PRESCHOOL BUT TWO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL I THINK THAT WE
HAVE ENOUGH?
WE HAVE COUNSELORS IN THE HIGH
SCHOOLS BUT THEY'RE NOT MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS THEIR ACADEMIC
COUNSELORS AND I THINK THAT
HOPEFULLY WITH THIS UP BEGINNING
I THINK. YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS WE CAN OVE
INTO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
THE. ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MIDDLE
SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS I THINK
IT'S A CRITICAL NEED AND I THINK
YOU OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE THE MOST IN A
SECOND AND WISHES TO PASS TO.
TO THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
CALDERON.
RUBIO LIVE REVIEW I GOT TO CHOI.
NOT TO CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
EXCUSE ME MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RESTS
REYES AYE STONE BY STONE AYE
THURMOND. THURMOND AYE THE BILL
ITSELF SIX ZERO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
.
AS MR SO CAN. WE GO AHEAD AND.
SEE.
GO BACK OVER OPEN THE. OPEN THE
ROLE FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ARAMBULA. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I.
THURMOND THURMOND AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE ABA TO JUST YOU
TO SANTIAGO GET PAST AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
DOCTOR CHOI DUMP BESIDE DUTCH
JOIN UP VOTING.
ARAMBULA.
YOU DON'T HAVE.
BUT FIRST.
YEP.
AND.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY TO
URGE SEVEN SIMPLY MEMBER EGGMAN
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I THURMOND. DORMANT
I.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
AB TWENTY TO NINETY TO ACQUIRE
CURRY.
DO PASSED EDUCATION.
ARAMBULA MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIN SHOW NO.
A MAIENSCHEIN I.
THURMOND. THURMOND AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON TO PASS TO PUBLIC SAFETY
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
BERMAN. THURMOND AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A BE TWENTY
SIX THIRTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL. DO PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE STONE AYE
THURMOND AYE THURMOND AYE.
EXCUSE MEAN ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUT
DEAL.
DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR TRY NO.
STONE.
STONE I.
THURMOND.
THURMOND AND.
COULDN'T YOU SEE ME.
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
EIGHTEEN A BEAK ZERO ZERO SEVEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
STAMPED.
I'M SORRY ONCE PROHIBITED AND.
YES.
YOU VOTED AGAINST GAP.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE.
AB THREE ZERO EIGHT EIGHT.
MAIENSCHEIN.
THURMOND.
THURMOND NINE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY SIX BERMAN.
THURMOND I.
AND WOOD AND.
YEAH.
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR A
DR GRANT.
AFTER FROM JUST LOOKING
SEC CONSENT CALENDAR.
THAT I'M GONNA AYE ARAMBULA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO SANTIAGO
AYE. ARAMBULA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN GLORIA.
ARAMBULA ARE THAT I'M GONNA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
TRINITY TO HER QUIRK ACQUIRE
CURRY.
ARAMBULA A LITTLE BELOW I.
I DO NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO ARAMBULA AYE ARAMBULA AYE.
I LIKE THAT.
I NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWO TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY FOUR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RANCH
ARAMBULA AYE ARAMBULA AYE.
A LITTLE
.
ALRIGHT WELL.
IT'S VERY.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT US.
THIS IS.
THE WAY YOU WILL HEAR.
CALLING ALL.
OKAY WILL GO HAVE AN ARE CLOSE
THE.
MEETING AT FOUR THIRTY.
MEETING ADJOURNED